good morning everyone um rep PNE could
you Le Us in the pledge
pleaseed
States One
Nation
indivisible andice for all thank you
everyone
welcome to legislative
Administration I'll open
the hearing on House Bill 1343 and
welcome the prime
sponsor representative Ross Barry thank
you thank you Mr chairman my name is
representative Ross Berry I represent
Hillsboro 39 Manchester's South End WS
68 and N about 30,000 workingclass
people um I am the chair of the house
election law committee which is where I
thought this bill would have been headed
dealing that it deals with election law
but you sometimes they don't always end
up where you think they're going to end
up um so House Bill 13343 what it does
is it establishes an extra procedure for
the use of um government uh
gubernatorial emergency orders
concerning election laws so let's
explain why I believe this is necessary
everything that we
do with the state involve the core of it
right is our election process right we
elect people every two years it's a
Cornerstone of the New Hampshire system
um our current executive orders allow
for we know a wide latitude U we've
recently made some curtails but they
happened even though those curtails
still have about a 28 day window before
the legislature could seek redress the
problem is in 28 uh 28 days in election
is a lifetime um so if we're going to
have a system where our corner office
can change our laws at will for 28 days
um or more we can't allow them to
unilaterally touch election laws um and
I'll give you some examples of both
sides could abuse this power so imagine
imag imag if you will Governor Barry
decides that voter fraud is an emergency
declares that
absentee number one source of voter
fraud which was actually true by the way
um absentee ballots are the number one
source of prosecution by the AG for
cases of wrongful voting declares voter
fraud a state of emergency says no
absentee ballots can be sent out or sent
in uh for the general election and the
legislature for 28 days can do nothing
about it that changes the outcome of an
election
right conversely let's say one of my
friends on the other side of theis
happens to be governed and declares
climate change a state of emergency and
says that everybody driving to the polls
creates a lot of carbon
emissions that's bad for the environment
that's an emergency we're doing nothing
but absentee ballots we're going to send
absentee ballots to everyone on the
voter list and they can send it back to
avoid carbon emissions these are two
things that are obviously patently
ridiculous right we believe that they
would never happen but under our
existing law they actually could um a
probably a more let's say realistic
abuse of power would be a seated
Governor looks at their poll numbers
decides they don't really like the way
the election's headed and tries to
postpone the election for 14 days to
give them two more weeks of campaigning
right every election law we have in the
book is written in a statute every
election law can be changed by executive
order we can't allow election laws to be
changed willy-nilly with by the whim of
one person so what this does is it keeps
in place uh a weather emergency because
we do have an exception for Town
elections uh we use the gray weather
station if there's a snow emergency uh
then we can postpone elections so that
stays the same that's very important
that stays the same um but otherwise
changes to election laws will require
the consent of the majority leader the
minority leader of both the house and
the Senate right um so that way both
parties have a say doesn't matter who's
in the corner office if the governor
tries to do something both parties have
to consent otherwise they can go through
the normal legislative process now I've
talked very briefly with the Secretary
of State about this U the secretary of
state says well I I probably just
wouldn't enforce an emergency order
unfortunately we have examples in the
last three years of emergency orders
being enforced by the Secretary of State
um and I don't think anybody here would
be really upset about those I don't I'm
not saying they were nefarious they were
bad I'm just saying that this is a
massive power that can be directly
targeted towards the foundation of how
we operate our government um and it
needs to be put in with some protections
um there are very limited instances
where I believe legitimately emergency
order should be used uh for um changing
election laws at whim um but I think
with leaving those in place we still
kind of maintain the flexibility um but
you still have the protection of it and
they don't have to the the majority
majority of minority leaders don't have
to sign anything they can send it
electronically it could be by phone call
it could be however they want to
communicate their consent to it um to
allow that flexibility to still exist
but we need to need to need to make sure
that this power is curtailed um
specifically about our election laws um
so I'm happy to answer any questions
about it um I I will remind the
committee you can vote to refer to my
committee if you'd like um and I'm happy
to hear it there too um but I'm happy to
answer any questions about why why I did
what I did um and why why I do believe
it is absolutely fundamentally necessary
and I do hope it would be bipartisan
because this this could go either way um
both parties should be aware this could
go either
way thank you I think the committee is a
little stunned by the idea of Governor
Barry up the start so uh so is my wife
it may be that there's a a momentary
silence here for a little bit
um are there any questions for represent
Pearson thank you Mr chairman uh just
for the record and for those on YouTube
and and the
like on you know line
electronic consent now you're talking
about four folks right two in the house
two in the Senate y this is a four Zer
vote there's no 3-1 vote there's not a
tie it's a four Zer vote and a four Zer
vote only it's a four Zer vote only both
parties both houses need to consent um
those are the leaders of the two parties
and the two bodies right um and at that
the reason I have it like that is
effectively right and obviously every
member gets an equal vote in the every
gets equal but if both Party leaders
from both houses are say saying yes this
is okay the likelihood that they could
pass legislation for whatever that
emergency change is is high right um
it's not a guarantee we've obviously
seen things go sideways before um but
it's high so that's how you that's how I
keep both um in there I originally
thought about doing the Secretary of
State actually having to be a 5 um but
the reality is if you have the majority
leader the minority leader the M of both
sides those are the people that elect um
that the Secretary of State and at that
point you probably have do have the
consent of the Secretary of State as
well probably obviously they may
disagree with that but I would assume
rationally that would be the
case
that uh representative
Shen thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um what about um same
day emergencies like
911 I mean that happened on the second
Tuesday of September it wasn't a primary
year but what if s like a same day of
like a outof the blue emergency happened
um would it still require the governor
to try to call for people together to
agree on so that's why it says
electronic means they don't have to
physically meet right um they don't have
to physically meet so that that that
that was specifically put in there to
allow for something like that thank
you representative sers thank you Mr
chair
thank you for taking the question so it
it actually brings up a couple questions
but I'll ask one at a time so uh first
one is notification what you just said
there so at this point if there's an
emergency
order who is being notified just those
four five six people or does the entire
legislator legislation get notified no
so it's just those it's just those four
people right in in the sense of an
emergency you need to act quickly right
to the example that representative shean
just said um you need to be able to move
quickly and certain situations I
recognize that I'm not trying to stop
that um conversely I do believe you need
the cons I do believe you need the
consent of some people from the
legislator before you start changing
things that directly affect the
legislator
um
followup yes please thank you so that's
concerning to me because as a legislator
now I'm feeling out of the loop there's
an emergency going on and I feel like
I'm out of loop maybe I'm not making the
decision but a decision is being made by
my majority or minority
leader and I don't even know the
situation is going on maybe and it I'm
just trying to figure out how do we
resolve that because now I'm getting to
the point of saying they're making
decisions and I have no idea well
currently you have no say um so it's
that would be my Counterpoint currently
you have no say so if you'd like to
reform the EO to a broader sense I'd be
happy to support that but currently you
have no say um and the legislator does
get notified for emergency or all the
other standard rules about emergency
orders apply it's just for things
involving election law there's an added
check before it can go into place um but
yes so currently I share your
frustration as a legislature but
currently you have no say
so any further
questions I have one oh representative
Pearson go ahead okay uh just just for
clarity too with the group of four the
group of four does not include the
speaker of the house it does not include
the president of the Senate no no it
does not so uh elections are elections
are partisan by Nature right so I
included the partisan leaders um if you
have the speaker right and the you you
have the speaker and the Senate
President you likely also have the
consent of the majority leaders of both
sides right um now that's not always the
case right there's in there have been
instance where the speaker is elected by
a minority by the minority and then a
then a coalition of the majority right
um but elections are partisan by Nature
I know people don't really like to
accept that but it is a fact um so I
included the partisan leaders of the
house and the Senate yes it was a
conscious
decision so my question is uh and this
relates to um rep Pearson's first uh
inquiry
um one one of them decides no they don't
like this cor three to one doesn't carry
it needs to be four that's it and then
what happens it says so it says by the
consent of all of the following just so
we're all there y doesn't go into place
they don't have the ability to do it
okay and so the governor doesn't have
that power then to declare no an
emergency no um what happens then um is
there any other um happen stance that
would occur does the governor have any
other Avenue um under any
other emergency order no no so this is
our elections are sacred they must be
protected at all costs changing them
should require a very high threshold
okay and I that's I I believe that to my
core um I believe you believe that um is
uh you list on line nine uh natural
technological man-made disaster major
proportions um is any of that defined
anywhere I believe that's the existing
statute I think it is but is that
defined uh that would be a question for
you that would I couldn't tell you uh I
I do have let's just say that I'm asking
it now so fair enough uh I I do have in
there about weather specifically there
is language in election law um about
weather um that I left in they actually
left in the exclusion um for there which
is underneath uh should be the gray it's
not going to list it's going to list the
RSA um which is underneath the 669 I
believe
so the point of my question was um just
to use one of the examples you came up
with was climate change um is it
possible for the governor to find that
uh climate change is a I don't know
natural technological or man-made
disaster uh the my understanding you
guys know more about EOS than I would
but my understanding is it's very
subjective to what one person
believes okay but since this is your
bill um you had the ability to change
anything you want on this legislation um
do you you you have not determin that
there's a need to change anything in
that in light of your question on or
your point onate change my intention is
not to try to is try to be as minimally
invasive to the existing EO law as
possible I just mer I merely want the
exemption for election law specifically
under 669 added um that's what I want I
don't I don't want to get involved into
that we have beaten that subject to
death right um and we've gotten to a
place where I think most people are
somewhat happy which means you've
probably gotten to the right spot um I
don't want to touch that I just want to
get the protections for our elections
put into there great no further
questions question um thank you very
much for your
testimony uh only other pin card I have
is uh for representative
Miku welcome to legislative
Administration thank you Mr chairman
good morning I'm representative Tim mchu
co-sponsor of the bill I represent the
town of marac Hillsboro County District
12 so I won't go over my written
testimony I submitted it to the clerk uh
I'll Echo a couple of things that
representative Barry said without being
too duplicative um obviously it's a
pretty simple Bill narrow in scope uh to
address an isolated change to
implementation of executive orders
specifically related to election
procedure my most obvious example is if
another pandemic occurs or when another
pandemic occurs right I'm sure that was
all in our minds um either party in the
corner office could just decide that we
will conduct that election during what
is potentially a pandemic period by mail
and the other party May disagree with
that again it could go either way so
this really should be a bipartisan
effort and should have bipartisan
support across the house and I believe
across the Senate as well so this is
finally a chance to not be reactionary
but be proactive and protect that is
what is most important to our democracy
which is the conduct of our
elections that's how I look at it it's
pretty simple that's why son is a
co-sponsor
um I hope you look favorably on it I
think representative Barry answered most
of the technical questions on the EOS
but I'm happy to to try to answer
anything that you may have remaining
thank you um other
questions I have one um since you're not
one of those four that are listed there
um and this kind of goes to rep seller's
earlier question um it would seem to me
that most all and I think I'm correct in
saying all of our our um emergency
Powers
um incorporates the entire legislature
um and this does not does that does that
worry you or does that bother you or
does that you think that that should be
something different so I have a fair
amount of confidence in the leadership
of both the majority and the minority
offices the the two partisan offices and
their ability to quickly communicate
um and and perhaps quickly solicit input
uh before they give give or withhold
consent for this type of thing so
practically speaking if consent is asked
for for a potential emergency order to
delay or alter the conduct of an
election I would expect both offices
would send an email out to their members
to see what they thought I I would I
would expect a quick caucus what happen
I mean in the in the horribly unlikely
event and uh let's never happens of
another uh Massive Attack on our country
that happens on the day of an election
such as 911 which potentially could have
been just by you know year off by a year
or so um I think that might be the one
case where if something happens at 8:45
and something else happens at
9:30 uh that that could be the situation
where widespread input from the entire
caucus of either side of either party
might be difficult
thank you um it would also seem possible
these days
um that that one of those four may be
um unable to be um reached you know
there are sailboats in the Caribbean
that people are on that uh that
occasionally can't uh or have their
power turned off um so it it's it's
possible um the question I guess is
whether those four are a safe enough
um group of people that would always be
able to be reached for purposes of an
emergency yeah that's a that's a great
question Mr chairman thanks for bringing
that up I mean perhaps or design those
two words could be added
um not sure if that's the exact right
wording or designate uh could be you
know
or assistant Majority Leader or I'm not
I'm not sure exactly what the righted
language would be but could be just or
designate thank you I'm sorry I put you
in that position it should have been a
question I think for the for the prime
and I think he's indicating he would
like to uh chime in oh could he's still
here okay oh all right uh thank you the
prime spor one further question rep yeah
thank you Mr chair thank you um and I
know you're the co-sponsor but I'm
wondering now it's like we selected four
PE po legislators to be on this but why
not the the um speaker of the house and
the Senate President yeah that I mean
that's a that's a great question I think
representative Barry addressed it
previously because by Nature uh the
those are
nonpartisan offices or bipartisan
offices right the speaker is elected by
the whole house and his his staff or and
elections are partisan conducted by
majority minority parties so it's their
leadership
specifically
okay thanks very much seeing no other
pin cards but I would uh offer the prime
sponsor
to come to the witness table again yeah
uh so to the point of are they going to
be unreachable I remind you we're
talking about elections and we're
talking about the majority and minority
leaders do you think they're going to be
on a cruise on Election Day do you think
they're going to be unreachable on
Election Day my guess is those four
individuals will actually be very
reachable on Election Day um so that
would be my that would be my my counter
punch to that is we are dealing with
elections and we are dealing with
partisan leaders um who are in charge of
getting their caucuses expanded uh and I
highly doubt uh that they will be
unreachable um or on a cruise and if
they are they probably won't be the
majority of minority leader much longer
okay so hold on
um uh two questions one is um it is
possible that um medical emergencies
come up but secondly um where where is
this for strictly the day of the
election it's well it's for all it's for
all of them right so I mean if if it's
an if it's emergency like that right if
we're talking about we're talking about
the 911 situation right um talk about
any situation it doesn't I don't see
that this is dealing strictly with the
the day of the election well correct but
you're the the the question you proposed
right is an immediacy issue right so an
immediacy issue would be on the day of
the election right what I I deal with
election laws right they're very focused
on one day um so if you're dealing with
something that's farther than 28 days
out the legislator actually gets to aine
in that um they do it's not like you
still need the consent on this bill to
change but the legislator because of the
existing EO laws actually gets to aine
in that so we are dealing with a very
narrow window in practicality whether
it's spelled out explicitly or not you
are dealing with by the way the EO law
is currently written a narrow window and
I highly doubt that they will be
unreachable if you want to put in some
sort of Safeguard I'd be open to it um
you know if they're medically
incapacitated or something um but you
know right now my my counter point would
be is what if the governor's medically
incapacitated I guess then goes
lieutenant governor I don't
know uh thanks that's most thanks for
your for your input um we're good I
think no other further questions thank
you having no other pink cards um and no
one in the audience that would like to
uh testify I will close the hearing on
um
we were supposed to be calling uh House
Bill 1080 I will open the hearing on
House Bill 1080 recognize the prime
sponsor representative
Nelson and just for the record um I'll
change the bill number you you've
written 1088 on here I'm going to change
that to 1080 okay no no no that's fine I
just wanted to not mark up your card
without your permission I'm very sorry I
actually think that I had B uh House
Bill 1080 in my committee yesterday
that's what was on my mind I apologize
for that no worries welcome to uh
legislative Administration if you could
introduce yourself for the YouTube
people than thank you Mr chairman and
good morning to the committee my name is
Jody Nelson I represent Rockingham 13 in
Derry I'm also the legislative co-chair
of of the legislative youth advisory
Council U proud to to be in that role
it's a group of very
impressive um wonderful young people I
am hoping Mr chairman it is acceptable
to you that I uh briefly introduce the
bill and have my legislative co-chair
speak to the bill because he did a lot
of the heavy
lifting that would be great thank okay
excellent thank you so um
this is James tal he's the uh he's the
Youth co-chair of our group and the two
of us um
were new to our roles um several months
ago and in trying to um organize
ourselves in the group we referred to
the RSA quite frequently and um realized
that we would like to try to
um change a little a little it for two
reasons to provide a little bit more
structure and reference for the current
Council but also um for uh ease in um
transferring or handing the torch to new
folks who will be coming after us and so
on and so forth and so uh literally the
title of the Bill of the analysis of of
the bill is really what Our intention
was refining existing practices and
procedures of the legislative youth
advisory Council
and
that's thank
you you will stick around for questions
all all right yeah thank you hello Mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is James TBO and as um
representative Nelson said I'm the Youth
co-chair of the council so we've been
serving with each other since around
April um I wasn't officially made chair
until July but I was serving as Vice
chair at the time when the um previous
chairman um abdicated his duties we'll
say um
so basically I I'm the author of this
bill um um representative Nelson was
kind enough to introduce it for me but
um this is something I've been working
on since August and it's um like she
said it's refining the practices and
procedures of our Council the um the
council provides a great outlet for
youth to get involved in state um
government and state politics um a great
way to um get connected with people I
mean I know that I knew nothing about
this world when I got started here as a
sophomore and now I've t testified so
many times before the legislature so
this is to really just clarify it so we
can get started each Council year more
quickly and to open it up to more
members so um the first change to it
would allow members um to apply age 14
rather than age 15 to introdu some of
the younger members more readily um but
the biggest change is that um it's
adding an application process right now
there's no clear application process
which makes it very hard to get the
appointments done because in theory the
governor the Speaker of the House the
president of the Senate and the
Secretary of State can appoint whomever
they want age 15 to 22 to the council
and the difficulty with that is they
don't necessarily have to um meet our
recommendation or meet our applications
that we have because we have an informal
application and that makes it
problematic because um and okay I'll use
an example from this year we have the
Secretary of State's office who said
that they won't um appoint anyone that
we send them an application for and
they're going to make the appointments
completely on their own well that would
be well and good but they don't have
anyone going to the Secretary of State's
office pursuing those vacancies so the
seats just remain vacant and they won't
work with us to get those seats filled
so we just have like three vacancies on
the council at this point because they
won't fill them um so this provides a
clear application process that they must
follow all applications must be
submitted to all the offices um there's
what I like to call an anti-nepotism
Clause um that prevents any student who
knows one of the officers personally
from being appointed by that officer um
just to prevent that sort of favoritism
from occurring um and really it just um
ensures that there's a clear timeline
for these appointments to happen so we
can get started on time so we can best
engage with the legislative process as
it's happening rather than after the
fact which has been one of the issues in
previous years we submit a lot of
testimony but typically it's after the
bills have already been V voted on and
that's something that we're trying to
correct this year and I've been working
very diligently to ensure that happens
um it's also adds a lot more language in
regards to collaboration with other
councils so it's adding a non- voting
member from the governor's youth
advisory Council um um as a member of
lak and so that will allow us to
coordinate with them better um on term
in terms of drug policy which is very
important for both of us and allow them
to work with us when it comes to
legislative policy which they are less
experienced in um it also adds um a
mandate for us to work with other states
youth advisory councils because that's
again something I've been trying to um
work with because across all of these
states all of our councils we have a
common goal of trying to increase youth
Civic engagement so we've been trying to
work together and by adding that
language we can have a clear mandate to
continue that into the future even after
I'm gone
um and it also adds language in regards
to um remote participation meetings so
if a member can't make it they can join
a meeting remotely and that is very
important because some of our members
they can't drive and they might be all
the way up in like the very North Point
of Coos County they can't necessarily
make it to conquered especially if it's
like in the middle of a blizzard or
something and maybe we'd reschedule but
we could it would also give us the
ability to have them participate
remotely if that if we choose to proceed
with an inperson meeting um it also adds
more clarity about what our annual
seminar would be it the statute as it's
currently written mandates that we have
an annual seminar um every August well
sometimes we don't get started in August
because of the appointment process now
hopefully that won't happen but now it
says instead of August within 30 days of
receiving the final appointments of that
Council year um and it also clarifies
what that um seminar will include which
is an in an instruction on parliamentary
procedure a tour of the state house and
other such things as would prove
beneficial to the council um it would
also um include that um several mandates
regarding um how we coordinate with
other councils and committees including
House and Senate committees um it says
that the legislative members will not
hold a vote which is how we typically
operate at this point except for the
member from the House of Representatives
who will be able to break any ties that
um come up um and it um makes statutory
um the rule that we already have in the
council regarding um subcommittees so um
instead of just being something that we
do as a like just a common practice of
the council now it's statutory that we
will divide into subcommittees based on
different issues of interest to um our
members um
and um most importantly to me is that it
adds language allowing two members of
lak to join the um New Hampshire State
Board of Education as non- voting
members several other states um have
non- voting members on their state
boards of education and we have it um
now as a statutory requirement that um
youth members are on all of our local
school boards so this would be extending
that almost exact same language um to
the State Board of Education so that our
students have input at the state level
but by doing it through liak it allows
us to better coordinate that with an
existing body that works with youth
policy and to make that appointment
process more streamlined rather than
trying to pick two students from across
the state through a different statute
and finally it um changes the May in um
the office of the speaker of the house
or the president of the Senate um May
provide reasonable staff assistance to
shall if requested by the co-chairs
which allows for us to get some support
from them and provides examples of what
that may include such as scheduling
rooms reserving um them for us to be
able to um meet here in the lob or
scheduling meetings and putting them in
the House and Senate calendars for
announcement um or um setting up video
conferencing as well or anything else
that we may need assistance with so it
just so the Bill generally just provides
lak with more support from the
legislature which I believe is would be
really beneficial to us and be able to
help support the youth in our state far
better than as the statute is currently
written and um representative Nelson and
I have talked and we'd be open to
amendments to the bill if there's
something that we see wrong if there
seen wrong with it but we really think
that the bill as it currently stands
will be able to drastically improve the
council and the way we are able to
function so with that that being said um
I think both of us will be happy to
answer any questions you might
have thank you Mr chairman um you're an
impressive young man thank you uh this
uh do I understand that this is a
complete rewrite of the existing statute
as it currently exists no so so it is a
repeal and reenact that is a choice by
the by OS as it um but it is really just
additive so most of the language in here
that is not um new is what already exist
in statute uh the um copy of the bill I
handed out highlights every single
Amendment to the bill so it's not a
complete rewrite but it's significant
additions to the bill I see um what
we're used to is uh is to have
italicized or bold language put in when
it's new Y and they chose to repeal and
reenact I don't know why
okay that'll make it a little more
difficult um are you willing to take
questions absolutely I've already asked
you some so it's kind of immaterial um
are there questions
for either the prime sponsor or the
coach uh yep
represent uh thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my questions um I
am very impressed with the amount of
work and knowledge and uh how you can
speak to this I I hope hope to be able
to do that one day
myself U my question I have two
questions uh first one is how many uh
members on the legislative youth
advisory Council right now so the
statutory limit is 21 one member from
the Senate one member from the House of
Representatives seven postsecondary
youth which is defined as anyone who
currently attends a New Hampshire
college or university um or someone
who's part of the New Hampshire
Workforce and then 12 secondary students
right now I believe we have 15 youth
members there are that we have I believe
four vacancies one being a secondary
student and three being post-secondary
so that is something that we do have an
issue with in terms we um we have a lot
of issues recruiting postsecondary
members we think that they provide a
great deal of insight into the council
um from a different perspective so we
think that um they do serve an important
role but they are certainly harder to
recruit for and the other issue is that
there's um with some of our former
members there's an issue with
communication so um some of them have
graduated and they've moved out of state
um but we never got a formal um notice
of that and for that reason it makes it
harder to coordinate with the appointing
officers to get them replaced because
there was no formal letter of
resignation
and so they have to like go through all
their processes to make sure you know
they can't reach this kid and um but so
that's something that we're currently
dealing with as well trying to get those
old members officially removed so that
we can um reappoint them of course
follow up follow up so my second
question is um I I'm wondering where in
the process any of your members uh study
the New Hampshire Constitution or the US
Constitution as you know or may not know
that uh we take this oath to uphold the
Constitution so uh many of us look at
legislation that we pass and ask
ourselves is it constitutional is that
something that your group follows in the
seminar process
or thank you for taking our question
representative we have actually
discussed that and we um with uh we're
we're organized ing um speakers to come
uh and you actually were somebody that
we thought would be somebody who would
be great to talk to us about that very
subject um so yes I think that's
important to
us yeah and speaking personally I I am
very passionate about um both the US and
the New Hampshire constitutions um so I
I would agree that we should absolutely
study it more maybe that's something
that we can work into the annual seminar
and one of the areas of so two of the
areas of focus that we really wanted to
have this year were in regards to civic
education and mental health so we were
looking into having um public forums um
on those issues and how we can try to
address them and work with the
legislature to address them from a youth
perspective so um we wanted so that
those public forums as we've had them in
the past include bringing in state
Commissioners and legislators and other
people involved with that process to try
to speak to those points so we would
probably bring in like School
administrators and the like for those
and that is something that we definitely
want to pursue because um we believe
that the civic education in the state is
severely lacking and needs significant
Improvement yes rep sers thank you Mr
chair as uh as uh chairman Hill stated
before we're not used to getting
documents like this so I my question is
what's the key is what does blue mean
what's pink mean what key on the first
page huh keys on the first PL first page
a up top I missed that thank you of
course when you take us out of our
comfort zone it's a little I totally
understand thank you Mr chair uh to
bounce off a little bit of what
repellers just said in three terms I've
never had uh legislative changes sent to
me multicolored that is um sorry about
that no no no don't don't presume that
I'm opposed to it I just I it's just
something I've I've read thousands of
bills and and have never had this before
so that's um I'm digesting it
and I like it on its surface immediately
but um what I'm getting my question to
you here is the The Advisory
Council has had some rocky periods yes
in the
past the current operation that that
you're
co-chairing do you feel that that is
working right
now and if it's
not the the areas to which you are
currently having problems would are they
would they be solved with what you've
handed us here I think so I think that
um as I've been running the council it's
been very effective and I've been very
happy to work with the people that we
have and I think that aot lot of our
issues in the past have come down to the
fact that there has been no real process
for appointments to happen and um quite
frankly um previous co-chairs um going
back quite a few years they took
applications um and then only sent in
the ones that they wanted appointed so
they may have gotten like like 20 or 30
and they sent in the 19 that they
thought would be best fit with their
part of an agenda and so by having a
clear process in place um that would
allow for only the best candidates to be
selected because all of the applications
would be completely transparent to all
of the app pointers and that is
something that as I've been personally
working with all of their offices
they've never seen from us before I and
that's something I've been trying to
change and they've been greatly
appreciative of that fact the fact that
they actually get a choice in who
they're appointing because in the past
they never got that choice it was a
false choice and that was certainly
violative of Statute as a current as it
currently stands but now it would be
even clearer and would provide an actual
process for those applications to be
submitted because in the past there was
never an actual application process so
it would allow for the students who are
best fit and the ones who will actually
best um represent the council and best
do their best work on the council to be
appointed rather than whoever the um
legislative co-chair thinks will be best
which is not necessarily the
case so
uh repes yeah thank you Mr chair so all
right now I see the
key but I'm just trying to and maybe I'm
just slow and I'm I'm new to this but
you got pink is that application what
what is that is that like a new section
is or is that um strike through meaning
it's deleted or I um anything
highlighted is additions to the bill so
that is okay um so I wanted that to be
an entirely new section on its own but
they decided OS decided when they were
drafting it to include it under 19k 2 um
but all of that is new language
regarding the application process
because app present on application
process doesn't
exist so so everything that's
highlighted is is addition yes is
addition okay sure that helps yeah um
and I do apologize um you know as you
know I see a lot of bills too and I
under understand that it's difficult
because it's not uh the changes are not
struck through or italicized um and it's
the way that OS decided for us to
present this bill it was a little bit
challenging and difficult for us as well
when we were trying to make sure that um
our our requests for the changes or
additions were in the bill so I do
apologize for that and um thank you to
James for trying to at least um help out
but I do know that it is confusing and I
apolog apologize for that no worries so
here's my intention with this uh for the
committee
um aside from that difficulty um I think
there's more here than meets the eye
with just uh the way this is drafted and
some of the other ideas that have been
brought up in the past so my intention
is to form a subcommittee um and have
rep uh she and chair the subcommittee um
I think we have rep Hobson rep nutting
Wong rep TIY um thus far um I put in the
calendar for the
7th 15th so we are um our
next or a session day that we have
coming up in
February um is the day the governor is
giving his uh inauguration
and that is going to start at
1:00 so uh the idea would be for the
subcommittee to meet in the morning of
that day um since everyone's already
planning on being here anyway for that
that session day so the subcommittee
would meet um I think it would be
advantageous but the chairman of the
subcommittee can do whatever she wants
um I would think it would be
advantageous to invite some of the
stakeholders obviously the legislative
Council um and rep Nelson and um and
begin the conversation at least from the
standpoint of the existing bill I have
seen um an amendment to that um come
floated through and that may need to be
um added into the mix but uh for me
there's
primarily I'm going to say two areas
that should be of concentration ation
one is um the idea of um
diversification uh the original
legislative youth advisory Council had a
mandate to for the council to be
Diversified both
geographically and um I guess interest
it would it would supposed to contain
may I speak to that well you will in a
second yep um it's supposed to contain
um Geographic uh children from all parts
of New Hampshire supposed to contain um
public private H School charter school
whatever it's very difficult with four
appointing offices that are um not in
communication to to come out with the
Diversified Council um it it I've seen
it happen for all my time here um so
that's one area that I think needs to be
uh looked at so that bleeds over into
the idea of um this application and pool
I don't believe in the current well I
know in the in the original documents
there was no application that was done
it was just an appointment by by the
speaker the Senate President the
Secretary of State and the governor no
applications no names were given to them
um that's somewhat evolved I think
outside of the document um that enables
the op the operation to exist but um I
think there's a number of things here
that need to be addressed I'm hoping the
study committee can identify those
things that need to be addressed um and
I think it wouldn't be bad um to come up
with some recommendations for the entire
committee um so let them meet on the
15th and then come back we have this is
not an early Bill we have until um Mid
mid-march before we uh need to have this
reported out so I think we have some
time um that's my intention you you
would like to make a comment sure so the
original language of the statute says
Geographic and socioeconomic diversity
it doesn't say anything about ideology
or about um um different schooling um
capacities although I would like to see
that included and I do add the word
ideological diversity to the um Statute
in this bill um and I would agree that
we need more diversity from
homeschooling and private schooling and
Charter schooling um that would be
excellent um and um in terms of the
study committee um I I guess I don't
really because we we spoke on the phone
previously and I drafted a lot of
amendments I thought addressed a lot of
the concerns so um I'm not sure why
there isn't more discussion on that
rather than trying to prolong the
process through a study committee but um
maybe I'm just not too familiar with the
process as a it fully plays out
understood so so this can be part of the
learning curve okay so um in this room
um the vice chair and I are king and
queen um so we are deciding that uh in
addition to you notice we didn't mention
the the amendment didn't bring it in
yeah um so what that I would believe
that that document um and quite frankly
it's up to the chair of the subcommittee
but that document would be part of that
study committee okay so
um she will have the ability to pick and
choose what comes out of this bill
that's going to be recommended to the
committee she will have pick and choose
what comes out of that Amendment she
will pick and choose whatever else comes
out of that committee so um we haven't
discounted the amendment sure it's just
part of we're looking at it in terms um
that we don't have the time as a full
committee to look at we're we're looking
at it individually and then have that
subcommittee come back and recommend to
us understood
okay yes R thank you Mr chair just a
point of clarification I think what
we're talking about here is a
subcommittee work session and we're not
prolonging it as a study committee where
study committees would push it no no is
a subcommittee work session where we
could get into the without having to
vote on anything we could get into the
very detailed of that Amendment make
some minor changes and then when that's
ready we bring it to the to the body so
so we're really not holding up the
process it's it's more it's just to
clarify it yep gotcha thank you um and
in
that oh
sorry us
have a bunch of
cards yeah yeah they all they all
gave
thank you uh good morning chairman Hill
and members of the committee thank you
for this opportunity to speak before you
my name is Rebecca leak I am a member of
the legislative youth advisory Council
also know known as lak and I speaking
today to urge you to pass HB 1080 with
the Amendments proposed by the
council I live in Andover and I'm a
full-time college student pursuing the
paralal major with Liberty University
online I became a member of lak this
past November after hearing about it
from a friend I believe that lak is a
wonderful opportunity for young people
it gives us an opportunity to voice our
beliefs and advise the legislature on
how we believe the legislation being
considered would affect the youth in the
state it further gives us an opportunity
to learn more about the passing of
legislation and about the current issues
in our state it exposes us to the Views
and opinions of other young people who
we would otherwise would have never met
and gives us a forum to explore and
debate relevant issues it also gives us
the opportunity to meet representatives
and senators and learn from their
knowledge and experience it has given me
in particular a reason to be so much
more informed on the legislation being
considered by the legislature I've
already learned so much from the
legislatures I've met my fellow lak
members and from the research I've done
as part of
lak as one of five post-secondary youth
currently on the council I believe
believe that both we and the council
benefit from our membership all the
advantages and opportunities of being a
member of lak that I listed before apply
to the older members just as much as to
the younger members furthermore we bring
different knowledge and experience to
the council for example I have
personally drawn on the paralal and
government classes that I've taken in
college in analyzing And discussing
various issues and bills lastly in
recommending hb180 to the council lak
recommends a few amendments to the
current text one of which directly
affects me the current law and Bill
requires that postsecondary members
attend a New Hampshire postsecondary
school or other New Hampshire training
or education program or be a member of
the New Hampshire Workforce as a
full-time college student who is taking
online classes with Liberty University I
technically do not meet those
requirements we therefore recommend that
requirements for postsecondary members
be expanded to include those who are
permanent residents of New Hampshire but
who take online classes from an out
ofate postsecondary school thank you
again for this opportunity to speak to
you I am open to questions thank you
very much I'm having a hard time not
giggling and not giggling not smiling
with with pleasure here um giggling was
not right um are there uh are there any
questions for uh rep
hubson thank you for taking my question
I just wanted to know if you have a copy
of your testimony I'd love to have that
in the thank
you thank you Mr chair so you basically
you're saying you're being left out
because you're taking online courses I
am currently a fully functioning member
of lak but according to current standard
that is technically in violation of the
current statute and the bill being
proposed in front of you so I would
recommend that being
changed I think when we drafted this
original
um it wasn't possible to take online
courses to do it so it just needs to be
updated I think more than anything um
anyone else thank you very much for your
testimony appreciate it we would like
that
copy um we have one more pink card uh
for Owen
O'Brien also ask for two minutes to
speak um also representing liak
welcome thank you for your time my name
is on O'Brien I'm from summersworth high
school um and I'm attending dmouth
coming this fall um I want to just take
a brief moment to explain I think
something of lak that isn't mentioned as
much um and that's like the local impact
of lak so after I was appointed I took
it as my goal to kind of reach out to
everybody in my city and surrounding
maybe friends in do Rochester Portsmith
so be it um of what they think of the
things that we're discussing in lak
that's been something that's super
important to me and it's also bringing a
greater representation to lak so even
though it's not mentioned in the bill
text I think that's what a lot of us are
doing and it's not mentioned but it's
super important and I just want to bring
that to your guys attention that we are
being diverse we're including a lot of
people and these discussions are not
staying in the rooms of the L they're
reaching far out and it's been really
beneficial for the uh representation and
for the impacts that it's brought in the
voices into lak so that's all I have to
say thank you
guys are you willing to take a question
or two yes sir so I have one um how is
it that uh the the legislation that lak
considers uh how is that chosen so we
have subcommittees um and what we do is
we find whatever requests that we find
uh interesting and relative to youth
that's what we put in our subcommittees
and then we discuss these subcommittees
once to twice a month um over Zoom
FaceTime Etc
um which we write up statements and that
kind of stuff so that's how we discuss
things and choose what bills we want to
uh speak on and you feel that that um
you're getting a broad range of of
issues from that um review of the of the
existing list of bills yeah um I think
that it's really important because
specifically when we have a lot of
people uh in the subcommittee so
normally ranges from six to eight um
some are a little smaller just depending
on interest but what I'm doing and what
some other officers are doing is we're
reaching out about these bills to other
people in the communities so we can hear
and talk about bills that maybe
ourselves aren't interested in but if
other people in our communities are
interested in them those are what should
be brought to attention that's what
we're doing we're representing the youth
as a whole and not just our own personal
beliefs thank you very much uh what do
you what have you chosen for a major um
right now I'm declared as public health
and policy thank you very much thank
you thank you Mr chair so and I I'm kind
of new to this whole area so the work
that you're doing and when you reach out
and these subcommittees you're
doing and are they non nonpartisan I'll
just correct that's what I'm trying to
say I just want to make sure we're
getting all sides definitely yep thank
you anyone else thank you very much
thank you impress a bunch of people
huh thanks again um I'm sure uh repan
will be in touch
for um any any in materials that need to
be brought forth on the 15th thanks very
much uh with that I'm going to close the
hearing on um host Bill
time being 5 11 and we have next uh
House Bill
1518 relative to legislative Ethics
Committee I do not
see
the prime sponsor in the room we're
checking to see if she's in the
hall if not um we will introduce the
bill and then um close
it seeing none um chair recognizes renza
to for the purposes of I costable
costable thank you
um for purposes of uh
introduction thank you Mr chair for the
record my name is Michael costell
representing Carol County District 8 in
a town of Freedom um I'm here to
introduce House Bill
1518 uh bill that increases membership
of the legislative Ethics Committee and
places prohibitions on members of the
committee will you take questions
sure give me your best
shot are there any questions for rep
costable seeing none you're off the
hook
um I'm not sure if anyone has
any input other than that for this um
repres representative well you are on
the Ethics Committee in this I have
input but I almost think we ought to
wait until we can hear from the sponsors
who this I do as well we will endeavor
to locate rep Penza thank you very much
uh I'm closing the hearing on
1518 next we will have um house
resolution 29 and now we're only five
minutes
late can you just hold on sure um if you
can hold just a second
repuls until we reset
here
uh house uh chair will recognize house
resolution 29 and recognize the prime
sponsor rep Schultz welcome to
legislative
Administration thanks for having me back
great to see my colleagues and
friends friends that are also colleagues
um I have a question question first so I
see the non- derain amendment how does
does with that I haven't seen the text
of it yet does that Wipe Out the
contents of this and replace it with uh
it does it says amend the title of
resolution by replacing it with the
following but that hearing will be at
one o'clock gotcha I just want to make
sure I understood the uh order of
operations here well well this is a
declaration of an economic Justice Bill
of Rights it is based on um essentially
the notion of common good that um
supports our existing system of
government of capitalism of uh you know
a robust democracy all of those things
um but as income inequality has become a
bigger issue and it has been harder for
even the middle class to survive dve as
labor rights have been eroded as pay is
very uh disperate even among our New
England neb neighbors where the minimum
wage is more than double in some places
what we have here when we default to the
federal where access to Affordable and
safe housing is a struggle uh where
we despite the fact that we have
enormously wonderful
resources uh of the mountains of the
ocean of so many lovely um places of
Beauty in this state it's a struggle to
in some places get unpolluted water uh
for drinking you know that by and large
what underg guards this is just the
common notion of really what the
founding fathers Look to You know and um
the Bill of Rights and the Declaration
of Independence all those things but as
our economy has become more more
complicated as the number of people in
in the wealthiest country on Earth in
one of the wealthiest States in that
country have become more and more
complicated um it has become clear that
we need to establish a baseline um not
just the floor but a thriving uh Bill of
Rights that would be uh enable so many
more people to maybe open a business not
worry so much about the basics so that
they can take care of the their children
in a reasonable way um I'd also like to
say at least for me it's inspired by uh
I know we don't typically talk about
religion and I am a strong supporter of
a separation of uh church and state but
for me personally um this represents the
things I believe as a Christian that um
those Among Us who are suffering who
can't care for themselves that it is
accumed upon the community to step up
and take care of those who are suffering
because they are sick uh
disa uh young
elderly um
unemployed I hope I didn't miss any I
probably did miss miss a category there
but by and large those would be the
folks that need you know a little extra
support from the community so that they
can live their fullest life um really
all of these philosophies underg any of
the discussions we have here but I would
like to think and I hope that they're
worded in a way that this isn't partisan
that this is something we can all stand
for that the common good is a basic
philosophy of of humanity you know
whether you have a religion or not you
know whe certainly that you don't need
to have one to have these values that
this is the way it's worded something
that we could all stand behind you know
you personally may not understand for
example gender oppression but because we
live in a free um country and in a state
that is so into Freedom that we have it
in our motto Live Free or Die that
living and Let Live in a
way uh that lifts up all of our citizens
is the best way for us
to um be good neighbors you know the
even if it's the uh good fences make
good neighbors sort of philosophy that
this is very new Hampshire of us so um
that's what the intent of this is uh
ideally I think this should be in our
constitution but that's not what this is
this isn't a constitutional uh um you
know what is it C cacr it's not a
cacr um so to put forth that we as a
House of Representatives do in a
bipartisan fashion look at these topics
and believe that at a common good
philosophy that we can look at as a
common ground that we can look at it as
a way to get Beyond partisan bickering
in no way shape or form do I see this as
something that is trying to
assert uh my political party in any way
but to foster a healthy Dialogue on what
is a reasonable economy here what is a
reasonable way to address low wages what
is a reasonable way
to fix a lot a number of issues is it
right that is it just is it free to know
that people are so crippled by for
example um medical debt that they can't
open a business that their decisions on
where they work um are really tied to
where can I get the best benefits not
where are my talents most needed um that
really also I would say the flip side of
this because I you know as a student of
political science from a young age now
I'm 53 that's a lot there's and I'm sure
it's true for some of you as long as
you've lived that have drawn to these
conversations I think this also isn't a
I see what you have and I want more of
that and I want yours that is not the
that is not what underlies this um I I
think those of us
who want that kind kind of a society and
I think we've gotten close to it at
times in our history um is definitely
not a let's just take all of the wealth
from this group and distribute it that's
a whole other system that I strongly
oppose um I was among the most uh
enthusiastic when Le vessa was here um
and he was a key part in ending
communism in in Eastern Europe so really
what is about is those of us and I think
it's a majority The Lion Share of us who
sure it'd be nice to be wealthy I maybe
will buy a Powerball ticket would be
nice if a relative you know would share
some wealth if they have it but that is
not my goal at all it was that I just
want to work hard if I'm able care for
my family in a way that's reasonable and
you know not in a way that is greedy in
a way that is fair in a way that is just
um and then if I'm unable because I'm
Ill or I have a disability that
prohibits my ability to work if I happen
to be unemployed through no fault of my
own uh if I'm a very young person or if
I'm elderly and unable to work or
certainly paid my dues so to speak in
society uh that we as a community
Community do what we can to be
supportive of those in need so this in
no way shape or form is anything other
than looking at the American dream
looking at what would really create a
free and just New Hampshire and um
Foster those conversations on policies
that can get there and I think that
there are plenty of areas for common
ground I do believe and I in my
conversations with people of any or no
party
uh that this is the sort of philosophy
that the average Granite stator would
very much robustly Embrace so uh not
everybody likes to have these
conversations in the sense that you know
this could be a series of
conversations uh getting to the details
of policy is probably something you
would enjoy more as do I in many ways
but I think having this kind of
conversation is just healthy for the
whole um for the whole whole house of uh
for the whole General Court of New
Hampshire and um
I've I guess raised an all of Branch or
however you want to look at it multiple
times and now I'm eager to schedule
rooms to say all right let's whoever
wants to talk about X Y or Z let's find
a way to just have those conversations
is what I'm hoping when this
passes um I would be willing to uh take
the lead in with others hopefully with a
republican as a co-chair of an economic
Justice caucus that can host robust
conversations bring in uh policy experts
on these topics of uh multiple
philosophies of use of government I
think that in doing so to finding that
Common Ground I think again like I said
um who benefits most is not me you know
I have these conversations all the time
I could do this on my own own I you know
I don't need the house quote unquote for
me I really am being selfless in the
sense that this is the kind kind of
conversation the granite state needs
this is what the people of New Hampshire
want this is what
um when we Thrive the most this is the
sort of uh philosophy or um framework
that would be best for the grand estate
and that sort of conversation has been
lacking on the whole it's been peace
meal and I think having that kind of
common ground and framework to to jump
off from is a healthy
thing and I could obviously speak for
many hours on each one of these I will
spare
you all set yeah okay um would you be
willing to take questions absolutely I I
will do my best uh are there any
questions for repal rep sellers
I actually have a lot but I we'll start
with one let's start with one yeah um I
I get the resolution I like the idea
thank you for writing it and nice
meeting you again yes it's good to see
your rep sellers
um I can you
explain Equitable and
affordable what what do you what is that
Vision to you because if this is a
resolution it's going to the whole state
sure I want to give the state an idea
what this means
sure ideally we have a society that you
know looks quite a bit like it is now
but uh wages are better we have uh a
minimum wage on par with all of our New
England neighbors we by defaul into to
the federal minimum wage are the
wealthiest state to do so and it is
harder unlike say a state like
Mississippi where the cost of living is
quite a bit more
affordable um it is a problem and we are
losing people uh we are losing workers
even if they stay here and live uh they
take jobs in other states because
they're going to make more so really a
strong New Hampshire would be on par
wage wise at the basic level our minimum
wage should be at least as good as the
lowest minimum wage in the states around
us which I think and so we have actually
a few experts here I'm happy to see I
think that would put us
at close to 15 or on the path to1 15
dollars an hour as a minimum wage um I
could continue on policy Point by policy
point but really at a basic level
equality and affordability and
accessibility really is just looking at
the basics um but not just as a floor
but as a what does it take to reasonably
raise a family what does it take to
educate children what does it take to
care for an elderly person who has
worked their whole lives until the point
they need to go into a nursing home I
mean I could keep going I mean these are
all people you and I know well and I
will say just as a caveat because I love
these conversations I would love to grab
a cup of coffee with you and just go
through all of your points and see where
we can find Common Ground that's the
sort of thing that I genuinely um um am
going to strive for as I seek to start a
economic Justice caucus again here but
um with a new hopefully bipartisan way
of doing that um I know from our
previous conversations that we do agree
on a few topics and that's okay I think
that's healthy I think having a
diversity of ideas and uh multiple
philosophies is healthy but where the
rubber meets the road is what is a
reasonable life for someone that isn't
um greedy I don't know for lack of a
better word that really looks at what is
a way for granite Staters to thrive in
the fairest most
just freest way that isn't extravagant
necessary you know people can have
extravagance you know they have it no
judgment genuinely but does it make
sense to have a societ where we have
such wealth in certain areas and again
I'm not anti- wealth I you know I would
like to have it someday it' be
nice but does it make sense that a
mother who is Raising her children and
is a single mom through no fault of her
own um has to spend most of her time
working at two different jobs just to
keep a an apartment or a home to get the
basics of food and all and medical bills
or whatever because in my district I
represent part of conquer a lot of
apartment buildings a lot of senior
housing um we also have public housing
in my district um too many people are
not meeting their basic needs and I have
a problem with that that we that we
haven't figured out a way when we're
pretty bril
I think all of us together uh a way to
make sure that those who are working
hard to be a part of our system and do
all that we ask them to do when we
emphasize things like personal
responsibility but then they can't do
the basics for their family you know
um I find
that and this isn't this is this isn't
in this but this is my own I find that
morally difficult
I find that morally questionable and so
to get to that I would never want it to
be let's take all of that person's
wealth and distributed it would be H
this person already is working maybe
they should only have to work one job at
a decent Fair wage and we should respect
that job we need to pump gas and we
needed attendant at that gas station
where we get also maybe our cup of
coffee maybe that person should have the
kind of dignity and respect that hard
work work should give them and their
family so they can at least meet the
basics um that is one answer that I
would like to see but I would also in
that conversation and with that cup of
coffee um love to hear what you think
that would
be any further
questions yeah re
Hopson thank you m uh Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um just these
are these are all great ideas I'm just
wondering how do you have you thought
about how this would all be paid
for how would that income or money be
distributed to people in need well I
think that's the same thing to look at
the Bill of Rights or you know the
pursuit of happiness how do you pay for
that as a philosophy and as a
declaration of the common good there is
no need for a budget per se is incumbent
upon all of us to look at these
questions and find the fairest way I
don't think that government needs to be
that involved is what I think you're
getting at I can't I mean we can have a
back and forth over again a cup of
coffee to get to what you mean by pay
for it but really um not that much
different than how things are now but
with better reasonable wages and with a
reasonable accommodation for those who
can't care for themselves as a basic but
there's no budget to this there's no
expectation that uh we're paying for
anything per
se is um I have a couple of quick
questions one is um why house resolution
why not bring the Senate into it you
know I'll do it differently next time um
this is start of a very complicated
albeit could be simple conversation
I think
uh we have a lot to talk about here in
the house and that's good enough for now
second part of that is
um if
this were not to pass the house is there
any reason why your idea or of the
establishment of a caucus um wouldn't
still go
through of course the caucus can still
go through but now we've had a little
bit of of a conversation here I am
mindful this takes your time I don't
take that lightly as a fellow
representative um and I'm genuine in
wanting this conversation but you're
right I could just start a caucus on my
own and just see who shows up but I
would like it to be more robust than
that I'm I know what I think I'm kind of
bored with what I think it needs to be a
shared
conversation um with folks like you and
me and all of us and each other and we
don't often the way our house is
structured and the way we politely
arrange how all these things work in the
house there really isn't a lot of chance
to before we actually vote for it have a
conversation that is fair and reasonable
that has to be outside of the of of the
meeting rooms to some degree we don't
have an opportunity to have these
conversations really usually we're ready
with our our policy points often from
our party's perspective and there really
is a debate and a tactics on both sides
but there's really not a conversation at
any point you know we're polite to the
people presenting we can't have a back
and forth in this process so we do need
to have a caucus regardless but this at
least starts the
conversation fair enough I'm sorry for
giving such long answers nope fair
enough um any other questions I have one
would you be um so kind as to fill out a
pin card for us yes sir that does me no
good down there absolutely that would be
great if we could get that up here for
the record um and appreciate your
testimony thank you Mr chair and thank
you committee I really do value your
time okay now the chair needs some help
um I have a hard time pronouncing a name
um and the organization I'm going to say
uh that the chair will welcome
Viola yeah I got that part um the rest
of it if you could introduce yourself
and the um the group you recognize uh
represent from Granite State I'm going
to say it's organizing
project
ah just the red button in the middle any
either one of them I
think not
there you go all right um good morning
and um thank you members of the house
and legislative committee uh thank you
for the opportunity to speak for the
record my name is Viola ksim I'm the
deputy director of the grand State
organizing project we are faith-based
organization that unites labor advocacy
groups individuals who are interested in
in working towards a mo just New
Hampshire um and I'm here in support of
hr29 uh that guarantees the freedom to
for my union uh access public education
Child Care affordable housing quality
accessible healthare and all the things
that we all need to thrive in our state
um this is not a new idea uh President
Franklin Roosevelt gave this uh in his
State of Union speech in
1944 um and they actually called it the
second Bill of Rights because um we
really cannot achieve Freedom true
Freedom unless people have Economic
Security so this is what this is is
talking about in my view I believe this
bill and we believe as well that this is
making a statement about the values as
people of New Hampshire as our state
what do we value really value people
working and having a fair wage so they
can afford basic needs do we value
people living Brea breathing clean air
and having clean water everywhere in the
state do we value public education that
really invests in our kids and our
future this is really a statement of
what we value as a state
um I I don't know how many of you here
wouldn't want to see the same basic
rights for people that you love your
family your community your constituents
I I believe we all want the same things
for the people that we love and we care
about and not some not everyone in our
state has those basic rights right now
so this is basically saying we recognize
that we are lacking in our state but
let's take this first step and really
recognize the things that we value and
the people that we value and the people
that we love by really passing this
resolution um and regardless of where
you come from regardless of your
geography your your gender your race
everyone in the state of New Hampshire
should have these as basic rights as
basic human needs
um and my other point that I wanted to
make here um was about the American
dream you know we talk about the
American dream a lot how can you have an
American dream when you don't have
affordable housing uh when you're
working three jobs when you have you dat
in student Lawns when you have all these
other things that are really stopping
you from really life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness you can do that and
in our state which is Live Free or Die
really are we living or are we dying you
know you cannot really live you not have
affordable housing people are dying on
the streets because of homelessness you
cannot live if you don't have health
care that's affordable and that's
accessible to you if you don't have
child care you're dying because you're
probably not working you're staying at
home instead of contributing to the
economy and you can't afford the cost of
child care so really what what what are
we trying to do as a state so I think
this is really making that statement and
we're already doing some things right
but I I think just come out and publicly
state that and say we value these things
we value our our residents we value the
people of newshire and we're just going
to stand by this and that's the first
step we have to recognize um this bill
so I hope that you will support this
bill and vote all to pass and I'm happy
to take any questions um if there any
thank you okay are there any
questions I have one um this you refer
to this as a bill and it is it is a
resol olution rather than a bill um
thank you for that correction no that's
I just um needed to say it um is there
um is anything going to change um with
your organization or your life if this
was not
adopted I feel like the spoken words say
a lot I feel this is a start of a
conversation if this is passed and we
can now start talking about okay we
value affordable housing or we value
child care we think every New Hampshire
resident should have a right to that how
do we make that possible maybe we'll
have more we'll be more intentional in
these programs and things that we are
lacking but I think making that public
statement makes me feel makes me feel
hopeful that the legislature is
listening that they they know what's
happening in the community and
something's going to be done about it
so give me hope thank you
um rep Sheen you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um you've brought up
a couple times in your testimony about
affordable housing affordable child care
and you want to get the conversation
started well the speaker of the house
set up two special committees um This
this term to
study um child care and affordable
housing these conversations are going on
already and um you also mentioned that
it's a right for people to have
affordable housing it's a right for
people to have a good wage it's a right
but all of these things cost money like
representative Hopson said and so um
someone's going to be paying for this
and so I just want to know what your
thoughts are who is going to be paying
for it is it going to be the state is it
going to be
taxpayers
um do you can you answer that thank you
yeah no um so let me first start with
the last piece that you talked about uh
the conversations yes are already
happening about child care and and
affordable housing and so many other
issues water quality that's we're
already seeing that in different
communities though there's no committee
that I know of uh so I I I believe
having these conversations and having
this resolution passed it's taking us
farther to really get everyone in New
Hampshire really engaged in the
discussion because I don't know how many
people know about those committees I do
know cuz I care I work about I work
around housing issues so I know about
that committee I know about the child
care committee cuz I have a child myself
um and so I know that person but making
this statement it's it's more than just
people that know about it and so it's
it's it's more people that will get
engaged in the process but also people
that start thinking what can we do
creatively to make sure that we resolve
these issues people that may not be
engaged right now and to your point
about paying um I believe right now we
have we most employers right can't find
can't find people to work because they
don't have child care the there already
things that are happening so that people
are being creative about how those
issues can be resolved whether it's
using a home care based system to take
care of the kids whether it's employers
are trying to find ways they can
accommodate schedules forward so things
are already taking place they're they're
finding creative ways to resolve that
issues so it doesn't mean that it's
coming from our tax dollars to pay for
those programs it's just making a
statement we recognize this should
be a value or something that we value as
a state let's find ways how we can
resolve this as a community as a state
as I I think that I don't see this being
a a a program that's going to put a
burden on the taxpayer to be paid
for
followup oh we're good uh repellers
thank you Mr
chair would you um would you probably
I'm asking you would you agree that a
lot of
these items in the
resolution would probably be resolved
with a better education especially in
New Hampshire because we're not very
good at educating our kids where 40 50%
of them are
failing I'm just thinking education
because that leads to better wages that
leads to better you know affordable
housing Etc so I'm just wondering what
your thought is on that so thank you yes
we definitely need to do more investing
in education in public education making
sure education is Affordable it's
accessible it's quality CU not all
schools are performing well because they
don't have enough resources uh so
definitely I agree with that but there
are some issues like affordable housing
I don't think it's because of Education
it's because we have a shortage and
we're not building as many houses as we
need to do and then the houses are being
built are too expensive for people to
afford yes people can get paid uh but we
need housing that's going to Target
everyone there are people that are
disabled for instance that can't work
they need housing that they can't afford
to live in we have uh seniors that are
living on Social Security we need
housing that they can live in so not
everyone is going to be making six
figure salary we're going to have
someone who's going to serve us coffee
maybe they're making 50,000 as a
full-time job and they can afford a
house for 500,000 so we need to care for
everyone in our community the the least
vulnerable people and people that are
doing well I don't think we should get
how the system is um is supporting
residents in New
Hampshire thank you um any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your time thank you very much
for your time I have
one last pink card um here again I'll
probably probably yeah probably you um
I'm going to say Claudia but uh if you
would pronounce your last name name uh
that would be helpful Estel Estel yeah
and I I have testimony that I I'm sorry
I didn't print it because my printer
wasn't being cooperative but I will you
can email I will email it to you that'
be great thank you welcome to
legislative Administration well thank
you very much chairman Hill and members
of the committee I appreciate being able
to speak in support of Representative
Schulz resolution for economic Justice
Bill of Rights I'm Claudia stelle I'm a
member of the economic Justice Mission
group of the United Church of Christ in
New Hampshire conference as a person of
faith I believe that every worker
deserves respect and a living wage for
their labor and every member of society
should feel valued and able to earn a
decent living that allows them to
provide basic needs for themselves and
their families food clothing housing
communication Transportation Medical
Care and education they should be able
to live in affordable housing in a
pleasant neighborhood safe from violence
and environmental hazards if it's a
rental property it should be clean and
wellmaintained by the landlord they
should be respected for their character
and the contributions to their family
job and Community free from
discrimination because of their race
religion gender age class ethnicity or
sexual orientation they should have
access to quality affordable child care
and Elder Care their children should be
able to attend good public schools that
are offer a rigorous academic and
Technical education for all abilities
with quality programs in the Arts and
extracurricular activities in athletics
and other interests and they should feel
safe at work and in their Community
protected by unions and their jobs if
that if they so choose and by a just and
fair police and justice system numerous
studies in various Fields highlight the
intersectionality of all these areas
supporting what our Common Sense already
tells us good health decent housing good
good education a clean environment and
Financial Security Al go together people
who live where there is clean air and
clean water not near polluting fa
factories or noisy highways have having
access to parks and nature preserves
that help better help Pro give them
better physical and mental health and
people who are financially secure have
better health because they are food and
housing secure and this allows them to
be able to learn better because they can
focus on the subject at hand rather than
being distracted by physical pain and or
hunger and worrying about how to pay
their bills reliable transportation and
good physical and mental health lead to
better attendance at school and work and
knowing that their children and Elders
are well cared for allows for better
concentration on work and all these lead
to better job performance and more
productive workers benefit the economy
and workers who feel valued and don't
have to worry about food and housing
health and Care their health or their
Health Care Transportation and Financial
Security and don't have to worry about
discrimination have more energy and time
to devote to enriching the lives of
their families and participating in
their
communities this is not a Pana view of
the world this is a moral view where
every human being has a right to earn a
decent living be respected to be healthy
and safe to be given G dignity for their
positive contributions to their family
work and Community because they are
human beings in New Hampshire this
right's shared by about half our workers
we know from the MIT living wage
calculator that the living wage for a
single person in New Hampshire is almost
$336,000 for one working adult with one
child renting a two-bedroom apartment is
almost
$75,000 and for two working adults with
one child renting a two-bedroom
apartment is almost $83,000
to earn these incomes hourly wages need
to be over $17 an hour for a single
person over $20 an hour for each of the
two adults or over $35 an hour for one
adult and one
child yesterday a senator quoted average
wages of $18 to $23 an hour in various
occupations from retail to health care
and while I don't doubt the figures
averages are highly influenced by
outliers I know that my members of my
family and among my friends people
working in retail and healthc Care are
earning less than 13 and I mean less
than 14 and $15 an hour and they
certainly would appreciate an extra four
to8 per hour added to their
pay we also know from the New Hampshire
fiscal policy Institute that one in four
households in New Hampshire have incomes
below
$50,000 in in 2022 and 177% of Granite
State households have incomes of less
than
$35,000 we know in 2023 the median cost
of a two-bedroom apartment with
utilities was
71764 per month or
$2,168 per
year we know that paying more than a
third of one's income on housing puts
one in financial risks so we can
conclude that many of those 25,000 25%
of households with incomes of less than
$50,000 are at Financial
Risk we know that poverty and financial
insecurity are very real in our state
and while our state poverty rate is 7%
lower than most other states I question
from a moral perspective if any poverty
is acceptable the picture of poverty in
New Hampshire varies by County with Coos
and Sullivan County having over 11%
poverty and by groups with more women
and children in poverty than men an
anecdotal data from um food pantries and
meal programs attest to a growing food
insecurity and poverty among the
elderly furthermore one and three
Granite Staters said that they could not
easily actually excuse me let me
rephrase that one in three Granite
Staters say that usual household
expenses were difficult or very
difficult to meet last year in 2023 and
27% of New Hampshire households do not
have $2,000 in
savings we also know that there is an
affordable housing and affordable child
care crisis in our state we've already
talked about that this morning and we
know that public education which
educates 90% of the children in our
state is under Financial strain because
of low State funding High Reliance on
property taxes and millions of tax
dollars being being spent to fund a
voucher program for private education
rather than supporting public education
we know that our state is cutting taxes
but not replacing lost Revenue with new
sources of
revenue we also have you know some
discouraging things happening like bills
that are attacking workers rights and
marginalized people in in our state
particularly lgbtq community and there
are bills that Ser further uh seek to
undermine public education and its
funding and now I find very discouraging
but I want to point out two encouraging
signs and I'm sure there are a lot of
other ones um Claremont for example
recognizes the threat of lead poisoning
to the health and educational attainment
of children and tests for lead exposure
before children begin School recognizing
the intersectionality between good
health being able to learn and becoming
a productive member of society it saves
money in the long run to do that it's
not that it's cheap it's just that you
it's you know um what do I want to say a
stitch and nine save Stitch and time
saves nine that kind of thinking is
makes sense um their bills to protect
our environment a couple were being
heard today um and that's good for the
health of our state and the well-being
of our economy because it will attract
citiz tourists and there are bills to
raise the minimum wage to increase
Financial Security and there are many
many more I believe that we need to keep
working on all of these
areas to be able and that are outlined
in this Bill of Rights and to help all
granted saders be able to live
productively and be able to pursue
happiness the bill is aspirational and
inspirational helping us to remember
that we are all parts of our society and
that when the least of us is doing
better we are all doing better to keep
our eyes on the prize of justice and
well-being for all so I urge you to
support this resolution thank you thank
you would you take questions if there
are any
certainly do we have
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank
you with that I have no other pink cards
um I would close the hearing on house
resolution
29 um we have a couple of hours um
till one
o'clock one hour and 10 minutes
oh it's not 10 o' we had one
hour I'm a digital guy I um so uh one
o'clock we'll be back here uh we follow
up with one hearing and then immediately
going to an executive session I'm
assuming you're caucusing with yeah I'd
like to see the just a few minutes where
where where will
you now or are you going to wait until
after
lunch I don't know if
if
okay I'm ready to open the hearing on um
what is considered a non-g gerain
amendment to
hr29 recognized the prime sponsor uh
representative James Spain representing
Rockingham 2 asking for 5 minutes
welcome to legislative
Administration thank you Mr chair
members of the
committee uh I bring forward this
amendment could you please introduce
your for the I am although you just
introduced me I'm representative James
Spain representing Rockingham
too and uh I bring forward this
amendment because I feel it's uh it's
more valuable for the strength of our
representative democracy and for the
overall health of our Republic to
educate the residents of New Hampshire
the citizens of New Hampshire about
their rights as outlined in the state
constitution rather than to pass a
resolution that enumerates a list of
so-called rights that exist nowhere in
our
constitution my Amendment replaces the
entire Bill and as a resolution it
directs the future house to consider
such education and access to the
Constitution uh you all have a copy I
can can answer any questions if you have
any thank you uh rep Blain um I have a
quick question procedurally I guess um
there's two amendments that we have that
both say amendment to hr29 one is
18h and the other one that says
026 H can you help us with minus 0026 h
okay so you have no idea what the one8 I
have no idea what that one is all right
I never got a copy of
that it is the same it would appear
That's one says unapproved and this one
has nothing on it but that's oh um
anyway okay I have
the'll in front of me and it says
unapproved on my copy but that's the way
OS gave it to me okay all right great um
thank you um bookkeeping out of the way
uh does anyone have any questions for
the prime
sponsor representative
sellers oh I'm
sorry I'm
sorry thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
coming in today representative W um I'm
I'm sure you are aware that these copies
of the Constitution are available to
everybody at the Secretary of State's
office yes I am I felt that uh people
don't know they can get them there and
as an education effort I believe you can
see here that I felt that it was uh
actually uh beneficial to offer them a
copy at certain times such as when they
register their motor vehicle uh when
they file for elected office I think
that's very important um that when they
reach the fourth grade and come here to
the state house for their tour they be
given one and then a followup maybe in
the eth grade and 12th grade which
spaces it out evenly across their high
school years and then of course uh when
they register to vote because of course
that's also important to voters to know
what their constitutional rights are
okay followup Mr chairman followup thank
you very much and again thank you for
coming in today I understand how
important this is um what I'm wondering
is do you have any idea of what this
would cost no I don't but uh the urge
because this is a resolution it's just a
resolu solution and and of course we
can't bind a future house to uh do
anything so what it's doing is is urging
the house in the future to consider a
fund and to initially fund it and then
to allow donations to be taken from
anybody who wants to offer donations to
keep the printing up and distributing
them anyone
else so I have one question um there was
a i I guess it's an were you aware um
there was an individual I think I think
it's now two terms ago um that had
offered and had carried through with it
um providing fourth grade constit state
constitutions to anyone um that asked
for them and he said he would go into
deeply into debt if he in order to
provide it are you aware of if what I I
have a feeling he was near Deerfield as
a matter of fact I don't remember who it
was I don't know of this bill well I
didn't know if it's still existed um you
mentioned fourth grade and eighth grade
um um is there any reason that you pick
those ages uh I picked the fourth grade
because that's when they come to the
State House typically and I know a lot
of the Reps such as myself if we meet
our class we try to get a bundle of
those from the Secretary of State's
office so we can hand them out to all of
our students who come um and so rather
than have them every rep have to
actually meet their class and hand them
out um that having them available say in
the gift shop when the class comes
through would be a good time to offer it
to them and then I figured uh if anybody
missed that fourth grade then in the eth
grade or 12th grade they could be
offered the same thing it doesn't say
they have to take one it's just being
offered to them at those
times uh thank you is there a reason
that you're um
putting forth this amendment um as a I
guess as a replacement to
hr29 well as I said in my my testimony
um I feel that it's it's more valuable
to actually strengthen our democracy and
protect our um our Republic by educating
everybody about what is actually
enumerated in the Constitution as their
rights um especially if they're going to
be running for office or any of these
other situations when when they're
voting and whatnot but uh and when
they're growing up and they're going
through the school system to have an
educated public that knows what their
rights are and these are concrete rights
these are not a a a wish list on a
resolution for rights that are not
enumerated somewhere these are actual
rights that are enumerated um and and I
felt that it was uh it was more
important thank you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your time thank you um I have
one other pink card I think at this
point um for this non gerain Amendment
um and that is uh rep
Schulz welcome back
to legislative
Administration there's a lot of things I
could say about this one um I would
first like to say why Target this
resolution and not show up for the
hearing for that resolution why
this one when you could take a stand if
you don't support it against the
resolution you can get a copy of the
Constitution right now for free uh from
the Secretary of State's office that's
what I did when I first became a
actually before I became a rep uh you
also can go online and get it for free
uh I think this
is
um I'm editing out a lot of words I
think it's Shenanigans why why this bill
uh get your own resolution and I say
that with kindness there's no reason to
Target this bill we should be able to
vote on the house floor and have a
conversation on every Bill instead of
tabling everything or at worst uh
co-acting it when I would consider this
a hostile Amendment uh I would hope uh
everyone would want to take a stand in
one way or the other rather than
avoiding the vote that's my testimony
and that's me being kind thank you um or
as kind as I can be are there any
further questions or any questions for
representative Schulz I have one um do
you have comments about the body of the
amendment well I when I said you can get
it for free
already uh that speaks for itself I
would think there is no need to uh
create something that already
exists but moreover why why not then
make it an addendum why not amend a
relevant Bill why not uh do your own
resolution I mean this makes no sense
okay but then so then it begs my
question to you Mr chair as a point of
information who decides what can be
introduced as a non- derine Amendment
who makes the decision that it's allowed
because I know uh in the recent past
folks have attempted to introduce non-an
amendments and those have been declared
out of order who makes the decision
ultimately to allow it is that you as
chair is it the speaker is it the clerk
is it uh some mystical process that only
leadership can have access to but I
think we should be able to understand
that process so we can all use that
process sure I'll do my best it's all of
those um so someone um comes up with a
non-gain and you can correct me if I'm
wrong um someone comes up with a
non-gain Amendment and um or an
amendment forget the non gerain for my
for a moment and if there is a if there
is a different part of the um different
section of the rsas that it speaks to or
any of those kind of things um I need to
get permission um from uh the speaker's
office and I think the clerk has
um a hand in some of that as well to um
to determine whether whether it's
germine or not Germain and then they
come back to me and say it's a non-gain
Amendment and then I need to schedule a
hearing which is what we're having here
um that's the process um so this was
something you allowed to happen I'm
sorry so this you were in on allowing it
to come forth in your committee then
it's a part of your duties as chair um I
wasn't allowed to um offer it as a and
as an
amendment or at least I went
to the to the bother um bad choice of
words but I went to the bother of
scheduling a hearing for because I
assumed this was a non-gain Amendment um
it doesn't deal with the same section um
as as the original bill um so it's safer
for me always to have a a public hearing
that we're having now over that
Amendment rather than just um bring it
up in terms of of the exact session
thank you yep but anyone can bring one
any time
and more often than not I think it is
still up to the chair but more often
than not I don't think I've
ever not accepted an amendment on any
basis um so just so you're aware thank
you and I know they can also just go
straight to the house floor as
well
um I think that may be ruled on for Jus
as well so I don't think you escape that
with the the house
floor okay thank you
you seeing no other pin cards I'm going
to close do you need this for this part
of this
sure more like a statement is that okay
I will listen to whatever you say we've
got 10 minutes before our exact session
in terms of it being a non-gain
Amendment and having seen other bills be
hijacked but in the executive session I
I appreciate that you brought it to a
public hearing first and didn't just
bring this into the exec session where
we weren't able to have the open
conversation so I just want to say I
appreciate that
yeah you got to give me a signal when
you're going to be paying a compliment
because then then I'll recognize you he
won't gamble you thanks very much uh
with that I'm closing the hearing on uh
the non remain amendment to
hr29
I just across the street and Ross
building
so so you can subscribe that so you can
subscribe all over the state we deliver
and do that so 12 different those
doing a commercial
[Music]
nowal have ever
doneal with and then if you only need
like four parsley only parley and
or it's more you still get the love of
the cooking and you're still cooking at
home it's just that you're putting the
ingredients together you have the recipe
and you're still making it but every
week the subscribers have 10 to 12
different we pull it all together and
theness of what am i g have for dinner
really
with we're opening the executive session
uh for legislative Administration we're
going to um begin with House Bill
1219 going a little bit of out of order
to uh accommodate the prime sponsor
who's in the room and actually a
co-sponsor as well is in the room
um so um I
will
recognize who's doing this you
who's who's making the motion on uh
representative sellers for a motion on
House Bill
1219 uh thank you Mr chair I'll make a
motion on 1219 hb1 1219 to
itl uh representative sers moves itl on
House Bill 1219 is there a
second representative Pearson
seconds
um would you like to offer any
discussion on PO Bill 129 just that um
from the testimony and all that we heard
on it um it's I think it's a great idea
and but I also believe that we're able
to do this now on a Case by case a bill
by Bill basis so I don't think it's
necessary to actually put into a
law to actually which would actually
create maybe uh uh further employment
employees and and and cost as far as to
the state and to the people thank you um
I'm going to take a quick second and
a manner of personal privilege here to
ex explain the the thinking um I think
from um from the side of the
itl
so um I'm a huge fan and I and I want to
make sure that everyone is clear I'm a
huge fan of the idea of longitudinal
studies um I do think and I buy in the
testimony that we do our budgeting based
on a snapshot of time um and I think
that there are bills that come before us
that demand a longer term view
um having said that um I think the
manner by which this bill
um proceeds to get to those longitudinal
studies isn't isn't advantageous to the
state um or to any future legislation
that requires these longitudinal studies
so my thinking is um or our thinking is
that um if if we look at just the
timeline of um assuming this bill were
to pass and we did a study beginning or
um we we passed the bill we went to the
house then it goes to the Senate it goes
through all of this process again for um
hearings then it goes to exec session
there then it goes to passage in the
Senate all of that is probably going to
take you until
May then we have to hope that the bill
passes at some point and then it goes
into the enroll bills process and you
heard a little bit about that um earlier
from the other bill um the fact that it
can take um an inordinate amount of time
before the bill actually gets to the
governor's desk for sign for signing
could be July or
August um then we get to the point of
having those people from the bill
actually appointed to this commission
which
um can take some time um even though
they are listed in here who who would be
from what area those people would come
from but there may be difficulty in
getting those people to agree to being
on the
commission bottom line is you then end
up with a report that has to come in by
November so you're probably looking at a
couple maybe three months of time for
this that um I forget his name Mr what
what was the ex representative that
testified Dan Dougall
um he he was saying there needs to be
extensive meetings and hearings on this
bill um so I'm not sure you would
actually even in that short time period
come up with um cogent and
recognizable um legislation that then
there would be a window that they could
enter that legislation in for next
session next year's session the
alternative is if we don't do this
commission now we don't vote for this
commission now which is the itl motion
by representative
sellers um the sponsor is given the
month of February March April May June
July August September October and
November almost 10 months to um
do a a essentially a commission with the
people that she's already announced that
she would like to have in this
commission have it done on an ad hoc
basis get nine additional months of
meeting time in there and have
a recommendations that can then be
drafted into into a bill that can go
directly to finance for the budget for
next year the theory um and I've spoken
with the chair of Finance about it he
probably doesn't appreciate me um
telling everyone that but um but the
idea of a of a longitudinal study um
does have
Merit one of the things that we could do
um would be to uh in that bill and I'd
be happy to co-sponsor that bill
actually um is to provide or um
appropriate some amount of money that
could be used for um hiring or sending
out an RFP
for um a type of firm like the two
gentlemen that were here talking about
longitudinal
studies um I specifically asked them if
they do um subcontracting work and they
said they do for some
states there would be nothing wrong with
us um hiring them for specific
legislation that probably hasn't been
entered yet or maybe it will be coming
back up um in the next term but hiring
them to do those longitudinal studies
with that allocated money from the
budget so I think you almost can gain a
year in that way shape or form you're
you're getting to the
end product of a longitudinal study but
you're getting to it without all of the
slowdown of the process of going through
having a commission approved and a
commission um filled with people and
then coming out with the with this the
recommendations of doing probably what I
just said of out of um having an
appropriation of the money I think it's
a much cleaner much faster way of
getting if the idea is to have a
longitudinal study done
that seems to be the way to do it rather
than go through the commission room so
with that long-winded approach I will be
voting itl but I will also be offering
to co-sponsor um the bill for November
uh representative wall yes U Mr chairman
before any votes taken before any vote
is taken um I think it' be helpful to
hear a response from the
sponsors
co-sponsor if we
could thank I appreciate that and this
is this isn't really a a a an ongoing
discussion or a hearing I understand but
um thank you according to rules it's my
understanding that um if the committee
votes for being able to hear a response
to that um we don't have to have a vote
I I'm happy to do that I'm I'm merely
pointing out that this is um
there is a motion on the floor it's been
seconded um I'm happy if the if the
prime sponsor would like to take a
minute or
two emphasis on the
minute you're not I don't think you've
quite understood this is not to do a
longitudinal study this is to create a
unit which would would provide us
longitudinal studies on the things that
we decide are most important to our our
bill making
process
and on
we on if we hired people on a part-time
basis for each one that would take going
through the legislature each time it's
been done twice that I can remember in
my 28 years
um that they hired outside people and in
those cases it was for a massive study
that was done for a year two years by by
um by 12 15 or more Specialists that
were involved in the thing and then
sometimes we didn't use
them but um but what this would be would
be something that we could rely on to do
the long toal studies as they came up
over time rather than um a
oneoff the whole idea was to not do one
offs and the and part of the problem um
the group that you were listening to
sits in States because without having
someone sitting in the state that the
people at DC can can uh talk with is
that each state is quite different and
the person who's sitting in the state
knows how to fit these things into that
state we all know New Hampshire is
really different particularly on
anything to do with money but so um that
that's just um I'm not sure that I could
take the time to to go talking with 11
people all all of um this term but on
without having a way to organize it and
we already had pretty much organized it
but the idea was that we'd get Buy in
from the Committees that would be most
using it which would be finance and
maybe ways in May raising means
definitely on the revenue estimate side
we have no outside Revenue estimates
except the dras
um but
um um it's up to the
committee I appreciate your point of
view and and and I do I did understand
that your goal was to have an
inhouse
Department um
my feeling is and and I'm I'm open to
criticism here my feeling is it would be
a much easier
cell
to have that next step of an inhouse um
Department if that's what's if if the
number of bills that we have that are um
would benefit from a longitudinal study
warrant it but it would be much better
much easier to get that
sale pasted um well this committee and
finance if we
had
a um actual example of here's here's
what this um oneoff in your term oneoff
study did and here's the information
that it gave us so that we could make a
better decision longer term um
it it in my in my world I call that a
pilot program um and so that there's
something that you can actually point to
rather than jumping in and building an
entire
department
um building a a small Department um with
staff and with everything else in order
to make that same point that that's
where I'm getting to U rep
yes Mr chair can I ask you a question
about that in my thinking just following
your
line that's what we're here for um
is when I think of some commissions and
this may be my na T so that's why I'm
looking to your expertise is that on
that commission to study the feasibility
isn't that in of itself the ability to
do that pilot program like just what you
asked for so wouldn't that make you like
can
the commission is it's coming to do that
feasibility they're doing that pilot are
you are you following my line like when
you use that language that's how my
thinking goes that well then yes we
would want the commission to study that
in that opportunity because that's an
organized fashion to do that I think I
understand do I misunderstand how that
works I I think I understand your your
point and um that's not how it Works in
my estimation from the language of the
bill okay um from the language um or the
the point of view that I have it would
be if we were doing this work on on a
specific piece of uh Family Medical
Leave Act um and we hired a group to do
the longitudinal study on that that is a
much different process than than what
the commission would be doing would be
still studying it and talking about it
in the abstract not with not with that
um a specific instance okay thank you
yep um something else occurred to me
while we were talking about that um I I
liken this too um and we just we just
had a bill in the last session um and I
think actually rip walner was involved
with it the bill to appropriate money
money for um recodification of the
education statutes I think that's a
similar type approach um there could
have been a commission to
study how we would Rec codify our
education statutes and that would be
similar to what this bill was instead
what happened was um a bill was
submitted to finance for an
appropriation of i n don't quote me on
it either 880 or
$100,000 to um for the doe to actually
um send out rfps and have somebody do it
um which seems again to shorten that
time span and again would help the state
of New Hampshire in that terms I
appreciate that example and that
explanation help me thank you further
discussion not for
me no I'm seeing none I will ask the
clerk to call the role um we're just to
remind everyone we're um we're voting on
an IO
motion for for the language in the bill
not for the longitudinal studies um on
um
House Bill
1219 all right thank you Mr chair um
motion of itl on
1219 uh Vice chair Shen
yes representative
costable
yes clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative mcarter yes
representative
Tierney yes representative sers
yes representative wall
no representative nutting Wong no
Representative
turot no representative
Richards no representative Lloyd
no William Dolan not here no okay so I'm
just gonna him uh Renee
montio I'm sorry representative montio
representative
payer okay and uh Mr chair
yes I representative Lloyd did I not
say oh I'm sorry I had it down as the
okay
so
um you think I'd have my act together
with all the time first one's always
right
okay so we have eight yay six
nay uh vot is 8 to six itl motion passes
I'm assuming there'll be
a minority minority report is there
going to be a Minority
Report okay
um that it would be great if we had that
by um tomorrow who wants to do
it anyone I can put
down I will say I will say two things
one is
um I've written I've written the
committee report already and have said
virtually exactly what I've said before
I am in no way shape or form against
longitudinal studies um and I also um
will reiterate in front of the whole
world here that I'm happy to co-sponsor
um that bill come come September um but
um but other than that um I don't think
this is the manner by which it was
should be done so we're there
itl um I'll happily
help right um as quickly as we can get
it in the quicker we can get it in the
calendar and quicker we can have the
discussion on the floor I guess um
thanks very much closing the exec
session on House Bill
1219 um moving now to House Bill
1363 um allowing members of the general
court to participate in the Department
of Health and Human Services employee
assistance
program
I would recognize rep costable for a
motion uh thank you Mr chair I move itl
chair Costo moves itl is there a second
seconded by rep
mcarter would rep cable have any
discussion uh yeah thank you
um
the um this bill basically allows for
the um members of the general court to
participate in the employee assistance
program um I would say the biggest
hurdle for me on this one was the two
reasons really one is that we're having
the taxpayers pay for it which um I
don't think has the um a high high
enough burden where we should be uh
putting that on the
taxpayers and um the second part of that
is that um in just a brief uh research
it seems that most of us um are already
covered in one way or another um and
those of us that aren't covered through
um our spouses uh insurance or our own
insurance um is covered by
211 um so with all that I think that
this bill is um
unnecessary um I'll just leave it
there thank you r h um further
discussion re
n yeah um I actually think this is great
fiscal policy um the fiscal note says
that it is
$117,000 to spend it's 17,000 one year
and then $1 18,000 the next year um as
I've noticed in a lot of our bills a lot
of them are like personal
grievances um and I think that having uh
services available to people might
actually save us a session day um which
is approximately $15,000 so if we get
you know like one bill from like
everyone
or you know from some of like our um
from we have a lot of people with like
more than 30 bills which is what I
figure is one session day worth of stuff
and if you count all of our um committee
meetings like I just think all that
money kind of adds up when we're talking
about personal
grievances um so I think that having
this uh money spent to help people I
think would actually save us a lot of
money um but yeah
thank you um GRE
mcarter thank you Mr chair um with
regards to that uh I have been the
beneficiary of the services at 211 as
recently as almost a year ago today um
when I needed help with my alcoholism it
was free and not on the backs of
taxpayers it's a service provided by the
United Way a charitable
organization which that's their purpose
is to to help people in crisis of any
kind whether it's uh a depressive issue
a substance abuse disorder or a
financial concern or food
insecurity they they
um can handle that entire spectrum of
issues that an employer uh an employee
assistance program can also handle but
it's all done with charitable donations
and dollars not taxpayer resources so
for that reason um I would concur with
rep costal that that this should be it
since there is a free resource available
to everyone not just us as
legislators um everyone in the state of
New Hampshire has access to 211 so thank
you thank you rep mcarter uh rep
sers thank you Mr chair I again that the
211 service which is already there and
to put this in place uh just for us it
it's redundant at this point since you
can get this probably if not the exact
very similar service so it's redundant
and and why why take up the expenses and
not only that the um they limited it to
three times in 2011 you can call as many
times as you want for any number of
problems so it just makes sense to to
stay with the 211 system and and this is
unnecessary
thank you rep rep here I just wanted to
ask a clarifying question um when this
says allowing members of the general
court that's just referring to elected
representatives and elected Senators not
staff that's my understanding I think
the staff already does that's what I
want to make sure okay
yep U just further discussion on I think
that the 211 resources just so valuable
and I love how many times we're saying
it in this committee meeting um for
folks to continue to get that uh word
out for the usage of that but that's a
problem in of of itself right that folks
don't always know 211 as an access and
sometimes you think through your
problems and your process through what
is available to you under that umbrella
of the insurance or that of as an
employee assistance program so I think
that it is a very valuable for the
general court to open this up um and
have employee assistance for our members
because it is just one additional
resource not not redundant but many
people have different paths for finding
their information and this is that type
of path that could open up if we're
already making the insurance and many of
our members are availing themselves to
that insurance this is within that same
path and I think really important for
our
members thank you R
Paul uh thank you Mr chairman um just
going along with what representative
Richard said um so people understand it
was probably in the late 1980s early 90s
when we got about our health
insurance we pay for it of course
through our own pockets as legislators
we we are not state employees but we are
able to buy into a program like state
employees so this is where represent
Richards is saying this would be like
that is that
correct
it's
different thank you it's um it's
the it's putting your employee
assistance and mental health thinking of
it as in general in healthare so using
the words like that there are many
aspects that are different so I can't
necessarily totally agree with your
statement on that more of it is
um thinking of Health in the in the most
holistic way and including mental health
in that holistic health approach um and
making that available to the general
court so that is where I would be in
agreement with your
statement um can I ask a clarifying
question is um are you saying that the
current voluntary medical plan that
legislators can buy
into um covers this program as
a I don't think so I thought that's what
you were just saying I don't think so
I've never had to do that thank goodness
goodness but
um I just thought that's what you were
saying I I don't know if it's true or
not I just don't know I I don't think
it's this program specifically I know
it's not this program
specifically um I'm guessing again I'm
not sure about the benefits in terms of
going to a counselor for example or
psychiatrist or
psychologist um I don't know if
insurance covers that I I just don't
know thank
you
um I just want to go more into detail
about what the employee assistance
program like it's not just therapy three
times um I know some of them will help
you get um will help you acquire Child
Care um and they're talking more about
like referrals to therapy and um helping
you uh with food assistance and um even
referring you over to 211 um just wanted
to make it clear wasn't like medical
stuff um there was an outstanding
question of um why would this
plan not follow the same procedure and
rules as um our
current buy into the medical and dental
that is a voluntary and paid for um by
the individual
legislator did the testimony answer that
in at all I'm not sure it was asked um
we can ask the clerk to review her notes
but
uh um rep
wall has an answer do you want the cor
answer the testimony question or no um
okay um State reps who participate in
the program and there are number who do
pay for the insurance out of their own
Pockets right and my question is why
this plan
wasn't um designed that same
way Dian um if I recall the um Prime
sponsor testimony she said it would be
um a nice perk for
legislators
gra tny and that perk is one of the
reasons that I have a problem with this
um
211 if they refer you to somebody like
United Way fine you don't have to pay
for it but if they refer you to a
particular
psychologist uh psychiatrist whatever
that's on your dime I know the first
three referrals
according to this bill are on the
state's dime that's something that every
other Tom Dick and Harry out there does
not have the option to get it's a perk
that we're receiving that no offense to
anybody in the room but we really
haven't
earned if we want to pay for it
ourselves the same as the medical one
then I really wouldn't have a problem
with it but the way it is now uhuh I'm
oppos
osed rep sers yeah thank you Mr chair it
was my understanding unless I'm confused
I they were really just referring the
state that it wasn't Services they were
providing they there was only referral
part of the program so we would refer
you to X Y or
Z respon
sir sure respon from rep he according to
what the testimony said the first three
they foot the bill
for they are paying for that the state
is okay so 211 don't do
that s i rep cable first sorry um just
to add to that there was no resolution
after three um we had asked about what
happens after three and there was there
was no resolution to that it was well
you know we're not going to charge
people um but that to me was not a
resolution to that question
um repr I just for clarification on my
recollection of the the very good um
long testimony that we had um the number
three is being used a lot here um and
that in the testimony because I asked
the question question um that it is
sometimes one for a person and it you
know is sometimes to your point could be
potentially more so um but as a reminder
also in the testimony is that it is an
existing staff and um the department own
no additional staff needed to assist the
general court they could do that within
their existing volume so um just to um
to clarify since the clerk doesn't have
the notes um uh because I could I asked
those questions I was just clarifying
that point of the testimony as well so
um that it is not um an additional
burden and potentially to rep n Wongs
could be um something that will save us
a little bit of time in the end as a
general court in the most positive way
of of uh an outcome of potentially
making this available but I think Mo
first and foremost this is something
that you know we need to continue to be
um availing uh our members to any mental
health assistance and making sure that
we think of mental health as
health so before I recognize rep costal
I think the three hours comes from the
brochure here that says 3 hours of
service per year is available to you
during your workday without using leave
time which we don't get at least I've
never seen it um it does say what kind
of help is available and it says the EAP
can link you with resources such as
alcohol drug abuse career retirement
counsil is clergy Community Mental heal
blah blah blah I don't see anywhere that
it
says they are
doing the actual
counseling um it it looks to me like
it's saying that you can link to
resources rep costable yeah thank you
just to the point on um it not needing
more staff and anything if that was
truly the case then why is there a cost
Associated it it would be a zero cost
they would come here and say we can do
this there's a few of you uh so where's
the cost coming from and I was just to
mention that is where the cost was
coming from that this will cost money uh
it is U so it's it's you're kind of
having it both ways it's like it either
this is going to cost more money which
means time and energy from from the
Department or it's not going to and
therefore there shouldn't be a cost
Associated to it so like which one is
it R
mcarter thank you Mr chair again you
just read it out loud that they they are
not the provider of the resource that
you're looking for if you call your EAP
if you have it at work or through this
program here through this state you're
not going to get a counselor on the
phone to talk you from crying for your
dog or your cat if they're going to put
you in touch with an agency that can
help you with that so this is kind of
just acting as an intermediary if it
works in a similar fashion to the way
the one I I've worked with for decades
they are just an intermediary I think
the confusion comes in and even in their
brochure as I go on it says the primary
goal of an EAP is to maintain an
employes ability to be fully productive
in the workplace getting to your point
um the EAP counselor can help you
identify problems and make referrals to
resources that offer appropriate
Services treatment or help that you need
the counselor may continue communication
with you as you take steps to alleviate
the
problem so
rep exactly so it's it's this is like uh
the person who answers the phone the day
you call is now your assigned case
worker and they're going to keep tabs on
you throughout the process they're going
to put you in touch with uh you know XYZ
sober house or whatever it is and then
they're going to check in on you
periodically to ensure you're you're
getting everything you need from this
service that we referred you to and if
not maybe that's not a good fit okay
let's try this one over here that person
that you initially reached out to and
got in touch with is not a mental health
counselor they're like your liaison for
the services they're not the person
they're putting you in touch with the
person thank you thank you further
discussion rep nutting one and uh back
to the finances again um so 211 is
funded by the taxpayers like it goes
through the United Way but the United
Way is heavily funded by local
governments um so to take up that
capacity with us when we have a program
that is being offered to us
um it can go either way um I just wanted
to point out that again um this is about
the cost of one session
day um so it's not millions of
dollars
rep I wondered whether we beating this
horse to death um do we have to go uh no
we don't um so we
have before us a motion of um
inexpedient to legislate and I will ask
the clerk
C okay thank you uh motion itl on HB
1363 Vice chair Shen
yes rep
Constable yes rep Hobson clerk votes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative mcarter yes
representative TIY yes representative
sellers yes representative wall yes no
representative nutting Wong no
Representative cherot
no representative Richards
no uh representative Lloyd no and
representative payer
yes oh oh did I say that out loud sorry
representative chair Greg
Hill yes sorry
nine
96 95
95 I did um yes I did let's finish this
one okay um so the
the the total was 9
to5 yep okay um so the bill is
it uh will there be a Minority Report
yes and who will do that I
okay sorry about same thing
tomorrow um close the hearing or close
the exact session on 1363 FN
um moving on to House Bill
1,000 um which is relative to
classifying New Hampshire legislative
Services as public service for certain
federal
purposes do I I would recognize rep
costable for a motion thank you Mr chair
I would move um itl on House Bill 1000
rep costable moves itl on House Bill
1000 is there second second by rep
mcarter rep Costo would you like to
speak to your motion uh yes Mr chair
thank you
um there there are a few things that
stick out for me that um I'm not going
to be able to um get
over
um first is that um we are not employees
of the state and
the um the blurring of the lines is is
can be intentional or it can be
anecdotal but I don't we're not we're
not employees and I think that needs to
be made clear and the only way that this
um program works is if you're um
employed by by a qualifying employer the
second part of this is also something
I'm not going to get past which is we
are a part-time legislature we're not
full-time
legislature um again mandatory for the
requirement the reason why this bill is
here is because we don't fit the
requirements they you're you're asking
me to bend the rules to fit the
requirements for a federal program that
we otherwise don't fit into
um and I can't get around that not only
on top of that we are bending the rules
for us as a personal benefit this is not
um is not a benefit for the rest of the
state and there's nothing in this bill
that um it's actually specifically says
current Representatives so so we have an
issue here where we we're potentially
voting on uh a personal benefit which is
um contrary to our ethical
guidelines uh so for those reasons
there's there's really nothing um that I
can see to bring forward and and and
amending that I can get behind so
therefore I'm I view it as inexpedient
to
legislate thank you rep cell for the
discussion rep nutting Wong again me
with money
um this bill um would just allow
um us to you know check a box saying
that we performed public service to
cancel out student debt um and like I
think that's a great idea because a we
are performing a public service I think
it will get more people to run for
office it costs us no money um in fact
would get us money back from the federal
government even though technically they
just cancel it so didn't really
ever no money is exchanging hands
um but I think it's a great program that
like we should be recognizing that we do
provide a huge value to the state and um
to the government um as state reps and
uh we should uh be able to recognize
that and to provide that as a benefit um
to our fellow State
reps thank you um I will point out it's
not just checking a box um it's having
someone certify
that a
legislator Works 30 hours a week and is
and that the the employer is
qualified um so it's more than just
checking it's certification under
penalties of perjury I
believe repres just as a followup um Mr
chair
Hill
um we heard testimony from the
clerk that his that office would do that
is that correct because now my memory is
a little
fuzzy do we need those notes again so
there were two things that um our clerk
mentioned one is that he is
basically certifying that we were
legislators during that time
period he is not certifying that we work
30 hours per week and therefore are
qualified um the in in the bill it's a
commissioner and um he had just stated
that he could do it but it's you could
amend it that he could do it but it's
under a commissioner not under him that
was was the other the second part that
he had said um yeah he didn't um other
states apparently do everything um
through the clerk because it is a clerk
function rather than yep rep
TIY when you when it's said that no
money changes hands well that's not
exactly true any student loans that get
forgiven that money is considered income
and it is taxable by the federal
government rep M
Carter also a a point of note that um a
debt is never forgiven somebody pays a
debt whether it's the dead or or the
dead e that debt always gets paid by
somebody it just might not be the person
who owes it so somebody pays
it further
discussion so there's also the
additional question and
this will really murky the waters I
think
um so there's
some train of thought that um that where
this would be a benefit
that um wouldn't be
broadly accepted by anyone else in the
in the public this would not um there
may even be someone willing to submit a
request to the Ethics Committee to find
out whether this benefit would um fall
under the category of um in excess of
what our gifts and honorarium might be I
don't know um but I do know that it may
be a question that we would want to have
um the Ethics Committee who we have a
member of in the audience here at the
moment um that it may be something that
the ethics committee wants to look at I
don't
know chman um I I was looking through
the ethics guidelines and that we all
have those in the books and um it's not
clear to me and the Ethics Committee
would need to meet and discuss this
yeah all all I bring it up is it's an
added unknown I guess at this point for
that um
but oh I was just going to add that um
the program is they have to be in
service for 10 years um and it doesn't
need to be 10 years at one place so it
would also just be certifying maybe that
like we were only here for a year or
something like that which would be less
than so I I can see how it can be
murkier as well oh I think it can be
murky as you want it to be um but it but
it's um it's
definitely um not as cut and dried as
some would have some would say and and
the um it does come down to two things I
think one is that
certification um of whether you would be
able to prove or I would be able to
prove if we had um work been in a state
rep for a period of time that during
that time we can certify and prove that
we have worked 30 hours um per week
fulltime
um I think is a high hurdle that any of
us I don't I'm not sure I could prove
that I work I'm sure I couldn't prove
that I work 30 hours some weeks I work
something different and some weeks I
don't but it is I think it's a
impossible thing to actually say with
certainty that you work 30 hours or
more but for some of us it'd be
easier
um further
questions seeing
none I will ask the clerk to call the
role
on itl for House Bill
1000 okay thank you Mr chair
um Vice chair Shen
yes representative costable yes clerk
votes yes representative Pearson yes
representative mcarter yes
representative tyranny yes
representative sers yes representative
wall yes representative nutting Wong
no Representative
turot no representative
Richards
yes representative Lloyd
no and representative payer
yes representative Hill yes why is that
so
11 yay 3
nay
three this regular
calendar I think
so will there be a yet I don't know I'm
asking is there going to be a Minority
Report or just going on anyone could we
put this on consent Mr chair um there's
no will no to it and it's purely up to
you 11 to
three so no Minority Report and on
consent
or okay
yeah
well
okay and we'll leave it on the regular
calendar 113 no um no Minority Report
Minority Report
right uh close the hearing on uh the
exact session on uh
hb1000 um we'll move
to House Bill
1290 and I will recognize rep conable
for a
motion thank you Mr chair um I move um
itl on House Bill
1290 rep costable moves House
Bill no you're good thank you though um
rep cell moves um itl uh is there a
second hi second rep Richard
seconds uh rep Cel would you like to
speak to your motion uh yes Mr chair
just briefly um that would be
appreciated yeah um though you know
there's members actually in this year uh
I heard of both both parties uh being
fired over their legislative activity so
this is not something that um you know
we take lightly but U given that this to
me this bill is unconstitutional uh
first off I don't think this is the role
uh proper role for for what the the
state can can force an employer to do um
and even getting into the weeds of it
there just seems to be so many more
questions on the Nuance of it because it
says um not discharged um for house
session but um you know what if that
wasn't the reason why you're getting
fired but that's what you claim you know
there there's going to be an issue where
you wouldn't you know it'd be a um an
argument over who said what um and for
that and a few other reasons I I find
this inexpedient to legislate Mr
chair uh rep sorry yes hi I just wanted
to ask a clarifying question of rep
Constable you you stated that it's
unconstitutional can you explain exactly
how it's unconstitutional beat me to
it uh
the uh there's certain things that the
legislature can can can do um there's
also uh in terms of private um employers
there's to me is to to be able to say
that uh a select few people cannot be
discharged after an employment uh is
beyond what we have the authority to do
so I I would say where is where are we
allowed to do it I would put it back
where where where do you find the power
to be able to prevent somebody from
being fired from a private um
Enterprise um it seems like that is a
direct we're getting directly involved
into the HR decisions of um a private
company she's biting her tongue I gotta
rep pay go ahead so I would I'm going to
continue to challenge you on on your
statement that it's unconstitutional
because this this um bill is very
similar to FMLA protection which is
already on the books and is considered
lawful and with employers and whatnot so
it's job protection it doesn't mean that
the employer has to pay you it just
means that your job is protected if
you're serving in the legislature so I I
just challenge the verbage of constit
unconstitutional that just does doesn't
sit right with me so I just want him to
put that in the
notes um before you go back and forth
this guy's been raising his hand three
or four times um we'll go here repti it
is not
unconstitutional it is perfectly
constitutional there is two entities
already that we have the power to do
this for and that is the National Guard
and the
reserves they can be called up and they
may not be fired from their job at all
for no matter how long that uh per call
up period is Right possible the other
one so what you guys are missing here is
that none of those people get to vote
for themselves that benefit the
difference here is that we are voting
for that benefit for ourselves we do not
have the authority to do that so that
that's what you guys are missing
here
so I will um add to the mix here
um it wasn't brought up although there
were questions that were asked um about
whether
um it would be possible for the and it's
not written in the language of the bill
whether it would be possible for the
employer
to uh
reassign um or
demote or do anything other than that
it's that part's not written in and and
if I look at the language of the um
fmli I'm pretty sure that it was a lot
thicker than the bill that we're looking
at here as far as all of the places that
you could the things that you could do
and the things you can't do um but
having said that I'm not
sure
the how feasible it would be um in a
couple of different areas um we we tried
to talk to if some I forget who asked
the question but we tried to talk about
um the number of employees if there was
an employer that had a thousand
employees it's a lot different than an
employer that has three employees um
it's also a lot
different with someone that is hired
when they were in the National Guard um
versus running for office I think think
that's somewhat valid um it's also
different than jury duty BEC because
you're Cho you're picked for jury duty
without um anyone's say so um there's a
lot of things in here that fit in that
gray area um there's even um employers
that aren't New Hampshire based um and
how they would uh handle something like
this so I I
I think while the intention may be good
um I think it's more I think it's one of
those situations that's better left
between the employer and the employee in
negotiation um I would like to see it
even prior to the employee running for
office quite frankly um but um but for
those reasons and others I will be
supporting the itl motion
is there any further
discussion yes rep yes from what I
understood you can also the policeman
can come to your house and get the
legislator and bring them right to the
voting
session can you can you elaborate on
that for
me the police or the sheriff if if it
needed to be done it could be gone to
your house and escort you to voting
oh I think I understand now you're
saying that if you're a State Rep yes if
you're State Rep and you've been elected
you Vol you voluntarily signed up to be
a state State Rep you won um the the
speaker can um
direct the police to go and bring you in
if there's a quorum issue or something
like that um true as far as I'm
concerned I just don't um I'm not
sure
I'm yeah I'm not sure where
that fits as far as
the um language of the bill though um
you can't be fired from it but you're
saying that you could um be forcibly
removed from your
business well but that's not um that's
are you comparing that in terms of the
um the situation for jury duty or what
are you I guess I'm not sure where what
you're saying that that piece of
information that's just what I
understood that it could be happened
could be done to have a quum right I
mean that's after you already been
elected right and of course they
probably I would hope they don't fire
you for that cuz they took you away is
that what you're thinking though that
this bill protects
that no it would just make it so it
could happen but I mean if you if you
went to session and then it created a
problem and you got fired this bill
would help out somehow
okay just kind of a statement rep wall
do you know of any time when they've
ever sent police to bring people back I
remember once that they were across the
the street at a different loc oh were
you he was one I remember that oh yes
our our Chairman's
notorious yeah they they've locked the
doors I mean that's happened multiple
times right I I
guess you I don't remember anybody the
state police being sent to a house were
is that they were to the best of my
knowledge they've never gone to people
homes but that's there were a couple
times when they did go across the street
they locked us in we were locked in
right we need to get back to the bill
yeah I I all of that this is really fun
but it's not get back to the bill it's
got nothing to do with the
Bill thank you oh no I think we
do thanks very much um now trip down
memory lane was fun um so is there any
further discussion on House Bill
none seeing none I will ask the clerk to
call the
role okay on the motion of itl for HB
1290 uh Vice chair Shen yes
representative costable yes clerk votes
yes representative Pearson yes
representative mcarter yes
representative tney yes representative
sers yes representative wall yes
representative nting Wong yes
representative
turot yes representative Richards yes
Lloyd
no and representative payer and
representative Hill
yes oops I'm
sorry 13 yay one nay do I have that
right
okay
um
any seeing hearing none okay so Will
beond consent 13
to1
um will it be a Minority
Report actually you can as a sub
yeah
thank you Mr chair I motion to itl HB
1152 I'll second that
all that without that um rep alers would
you like to speak to your motion uh
thank you Mr chair uh just that um what
have to do a flag for everybody that's
the concern flag pools are only so tall
so thinking about half Mass you know
what happens when the lower flags that
are lower are they hanging on the ground
at that point and stuff and um
you know we we just I don't like to see
one-offs I mean if you do it for one one
group you may have to do it or you
should be doing it for every group so
that's what that's why I'm I I'm
suggesting itl not suggesting voting
itl thank you rep sers uh rep PA would
you like to speak to your second thank
you Mr chairman um mental health is a
very big issue right now it's a very
important issue the flag is very
important to me the flag represents that
we're supporting getting mental health
care for people I believe the flag would
be best shown at places like the state
hospital like places where people can re
receive counseling psychiatric help
psychological help hospitals in general
um I think that's where it would be most
noticeable and be like advertising we're
here to help you that's the way I look
at this particular flag um I don't see
where flying at the State House is going
to draw enough attention to the issue to
really help the people who need it I'd
rather see it out there where as I said
where people can go for help thank you
thank you um I would like to say in
addition to the mental health hospital
but I would think a perfect spot and it
and it would be within your purview on
the Historical Society historical
committee um the two flag poles on
either side of Governor wet statute out
there um actually Mr chairman I had
wondered when that was going to happen
we haven't got fly Poes there yet but I
actually thought that would be an
appropriate place to have it if we have
it on state property and we all know why
I
presume yeah thank you yeah I agree I I
think everyone should know the governor
wet story um all you have to do is speak
to all all you have to do is uh speak to
the person who gives the tour who came
in for the testimony or go on one of her
one of her tours as well so um I think
that that is a place we should encourage
further discussion for this and
appreciate you bringing that up Mr shair
or um speaker of arus chlif will explain
the story to you anytime you'd like um
there is also another point I think
aside from aside from the flag um but
the people that were here and spoke
eloquently to it left buttons on the end
of the table um to me and maybe it's
just my personal view um that would be a
much more powerful way of
getting the the recognition that they're
seeking um to me than this and I do
agree um with rep PA that this is an
important issue and and does need the
recognition I just don't think this is
it but um but if anyone has one of those
buttons I think that's a great way to do
it and I would encourage those to be uh
handed out um further discussion or I'll
ask the clerk to call the
role
CL okay on the motion of itl for
hb152 vice chair Sheen yes
representative costable yes clerk votes
yes representative Pearson yes
representative mcarter yes
representative tyy yes representative
sers yes representative wall yes
representative nting Wong yes
representative cherot yes representative
Richards yes representative Lloyd
yes and representative
payer and representative uh Greg Hill
chair
yes
14 yay that is
unanimous objection to consent hearing
none that bill will be on
consent um I think that closes our exec
session uh no it doesn't I'm sorry um
wishful thinking um host Bill um will
continue the exact session House Bill
1666 FN uh relative to income reporting
requirements for lobbyists uh the chair
would recognize rep Sheen for a
motion yes I move a to pass for HB
1666 uh repan moves ought to pass is
there a
second um rep mcarter move uh seconds
there is a the bill is open to further
Amendment and I have that Amendment
before
us
um it
is it is uh Amendment
0h and I'll pass that around
and repan would you like to move to that
Amendment yes I'm move um amendment
number 202
24-38 is there a second to the
amendment seconded by RB
Tierney um would you like to speak to
the amendment yes I
would um this amendment
um uh we we've spoken to the Secretary
of State's office we've spoken to the
prime sponsor of the bill um and what
this amendment does is
um it basically moves all of the
reporting paperwork that lobbyists have
to um fill out um handwritten uh
paperwork um they can now do that online
um the Secretary of State's office is
going to work on getting all those forms
online this amendment also adds um an
online
uh registration fee when when lobbyist
come comes in to register to to Lobby
here in in the state house um they need
to register and so this registration
form will be online as
well um this uh Amendment also um brings
um the reporting periods down from four
times a year quarterly now it's uh three
times a
year you right it changes the date um to
January 31st May 31st and September
30th in the effective date right and
then the effective date it will be
January 1st 2027 and I know that sounds
far away but um it will give the
Secretary of State's office time to
uh to um get all these things
online
I'll add a couple of
things um one is the Secretary of State
um office didn't have and and has this
on their list of things to do um but the
election getting a lot of the election
law things online and and um realigned
um to be done
electronically uh took a higher priority
so they came and asked us for um we we
showed them the prime sponsors request
um in total including the bill language
um and they indicated without so many
words that the um that some of that was
language was was information that's
already requested although they did
admit that it may be difficult to weed
through and to to dis um dissimilate and
and reassemble because it is um in some
cases handwritten and it is out of form
um a uniform form so they took a look at
what the prime sponsor gave us in an
amendment to um to create this online or
or put it online and in a uniform form
and they added to that the fact fact
that um um it would be necessary for for
lobbyists to be able to file um
electronically their their just plain
registration to be a lobbyist so um with
that they suggested that we do this in
stages one is um I'll get there one is
to um put this all online and then if
there are other additional pieces of
information that are being requested um
do that in a separate piece of
legislation so with that um rep wall
thank you very much Mr chairman just a
reminder that people who checked in um
online all supported this there were I
think 6 one two three people who support
this
bill and it's a good thing uh I think
it's going to help lobbyists we've heard
testimony in years past where sometimes
they get annoyed because after report so
frequently and this and they've asked
for being able to do it online so I
think this will be a good thing thank
you thank you rep all further
discussion I'm
sorry did you need a motion for the
amendment or is it as amended I think it
was
offered right and so what we would be
doing is we would vote on the amendment
but I can easily take if there's any
objection I can take a Voice vote on the
amendment and um I can do that now yeah
we're ready to go
um um all those in favor of the
amendment signify by saying I I all
those
oppose seeing none so we've adopted the
amendment now we would be adopting House
Bill
as amended is there any further
discussion seeing none I will ask the
clerk to call the rooll okay
hot as amended
okay I'm
sorry on o to pass as amended for hb1
1666 uh Vice chair Shen yes
representative costal yes clerk votes
yes representative Pearson yes
representative mcarter yes
representative Tierney yes
representative sers yes representative
wall yes representative nting Wong yes
representative turot yes representative
Richards yes representative Lloyd yes
representative payer yes and chair Hill
yes yes okay so that's unanimous it was
one two three four
five
yay consent okay consent
without are we going to be able to do
consent on this on a what on this bill
are we going to be able to um shouldn't
be a problem because we've removed the
reason that there was an FN okay perfect
so I don't know any okay it's a good
point but I think we're
good um
if not then it won't be but um we're
good to go uh the only piece of added
information um anyone that needs a
report I'll need that um tomorrow
lunchtime latest um and we've set up
another meeting uh there's going to be
if everyone isn't aware there's going to
be three um actually I think there's
four Thursdays in a row not the last
Thursday St there's this is a weird
February we've got um five Thursdays I
think in February um but the last one
will not be a house session all the
others will be so um and the four 15th
is the is the governor's
um State of the State thank you and
that's and that will be um starting at 1
in the afternoon there will be a
subcommittee meeting in the morning for
those that were appointed to that
and which is you um and then um I think
that's about it right um then we'll have
hearings on our last three hearings are
going to be on February
14th and then we'll just have exec
session and we'll be
done the seventh yes we have um the but
the last those ones the seventh is is
already been put on the calendar I was
trying to give you the update of um the
next one that's coming which would be
the 14th and that would be the
end my little gift to
you um no returns so um that's it
anybody else have anything that we need
to know I don't think so thank you very
much everyone how about the clerk
light